e
e e
okay it's a.m. we're going to get going
um representative toner would you like
to lead us in the
pledge
okay I'm sorry
okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing for the house election law
committee for House Bill 684 uh relative
to preventing the use of student
identification cards as a means to
obtain a ballot um sponsors I'm sorry
I'm still getting my pink cards here 684
do we have someone here to introduce the
bill awesomeness uh
oh represent are you here
that's fine please
do uh good morning uh for the record my
name is U
po uh representing Mar Mark 10 hook Dan
Barton uh I'm here to introduce House
Bill
684 uh and act preventing the use of
student identification cards as a mean
to obtain a
ballot uh I want to thank this committee
uh for your work uh making uh election
accessible but also secure and uh I I
believe this bill uh is uh making the
right balance of uh securing our
elections and it's uh very important
uh for my district and for my town as
well because uh uh in my town we have
quite a few college students voting and
there are always some uh friction uh and
U um misunderstanding uh on part of some
students like um uh if they can vote uh
um sometimes they Doms on border of two
Town sometimes they even don't know what
town they're voting in uh sometimes they
don't know if they can vote in New
Hampshire at all what documents they
should provide so this bill uh uh
clarifies uh uh what documents you need
to provide uh for voting uh so uh please
support it uh uh the prime sponsor
couldn't be here uh and I'm was happy to
introduce it but uh I will will not be
taking uh questions uh because uh um I I
sit on another committee it's not uh my
field of interest but please consider it
thank you okay um next up is Bonnie
Bruno um I I don't have what town are
you from Miss Bruno Alice uh we will be
on our two-minute clock today um oh
actually welcome back yeah
yeah sorry yeah no I I've been talking
about very positively anybody ask I've
been like super pump so uh let me get my
clock going cuz I'm oh wait wait I was
going to do a little intro though don't
study yet I was going to say back by
popular demand is the fire act part two
improv I love it let's go on the okay so
I'm here to oppose 684 and the other
bills this afternoon that I cannot be
here for even though I knew the date and
time of them because I have other
commitments so being able to oppose
early and do testimony even though I
knew the date and time of them it was
good to be able to do that little
reference back to the last time that I
testified anyway today I just want to
say can we stop this now can we just
stop I would say there was a problem
with the elections in November but it
wasn't voter fraud I don't like that we
have a trifecta plus the executive
Council so I have a problem with that
election but I don't think that there
was any voter fraud in that that I have
other problems with that election
because here I have to sit again setting
an alarm for 6:00 a.m. to get up here
and get here to conquered I'm retired
now for lack of a better word I thought
I was going to be having fun but for the
first time in 24 years of living in this
state I am constantly coming up here
this year and having to sit here and say
please stop this these bootes do these
bills do not help voters have access
this is not what people voted for 29,000
plus people signed in on a different
bill that I can't talk about here but
read the room this is not what people
voted for I don't know what they voted
for back in November but it wasn't this
so I'm asking you just stop let's do
better laws to help people access the
ballot make it not as confusing for
people as students to know what to do
what id to have but their ID is valid
and then if you have a senior who has a
a license that's expired more in the
year put that on a billboard coming into
New Hampshire letting the seniors know
that you that they're not who they are
when their license is expired for after
the year and they have to go make
efforts to go get another ID let's put
that on a billboard people aren't like
this is not what they voted for I don't
know what they voted for but this is not
what they voted for so today I'm just
asking you can we just stop isn't there
a high road that we can take we have to
share this state I have to share it I
didn't vote for this I didn't vote
Republican but I definitely didn't vote
for this and I don't know if other
people really voted for this because
once they actually know what's the
content of some of these bills they sign
in like in the
thousands so so like let's share the
state let's find a high road please can
we just stop this all right thank you m
BR your time has expired will you be
taking questions from the committee I'd
be happy to take a question from the are
there questions from the committee s
none thank you all right thank you it is
good to see you yeah I'm sorry that I
didn't immediately recognize your name
but I did recognize like when I saw you
pop up oh
yeah um next up is Kevin Blanchett from
conquered and once again two- minute
clock welcome to election law Mr blanch
I don't think we've seen you before uh
thank you very much this is my first
time here I am speaking to speak on to
oppose this due to accessibility issues
for people who um struggle with
disabilities I have provided written
testimony online but I'll be reading
that
here uh as a professor at a university
in New Hampshire a li licensed mental
health counselor in the state and a
transplant from another state I am
concerned with the implications of
removing student IDs from the list of
acceptable forms of identification for a
person I work with a person who is
currently enrolling in school at the
moment they do not have valid photo
identification and the process to obtain
this has too many steps for them to
remember understand and follow through
with
completing their cognitive imper ments
impact their ability to follow
step-by-step processes and they are
limited in their access to supports with
completing such tasks they are also
limited to the knowledge about uh local
election laws and without supports
around them informing them they would
not know what id is necessary and would
just bring the IDS they have in their
wallet while processes are difficult for
them to understand and follow through
with their brain is able to compreh
conceptual knowledge and Community
College is an option for them they are
also able to understand candidates
platforms and issues on the ballot
making them cognitively able to vote
without being able to use their college
ID they will likely be in a scenario of
not being able to
vote this person is not alone in their
experience there are many students in
the state who do not know this bill is
being discussed and do not have other
forms of ID readily available we should
not expect that everyone in the state is
aware of the constantly changing rules
on voting as many students are more
focused on their studies as they should
be Mr Blanchet um have to actually
conclude your remarks your time has
expired um and that's right about at the
end so we can end there thank
you apologize um as a note Mr it look
like the PDF you uploaded online was
corrupted I just tried to pull it um so
if you wouldn't mind either emailing it
to me or the committee or trying to
resubmit it um but I couldn't load it I
was trying to load it and I couldn't so
if you could just resubmit that that
would be awesome I appreciate you
letting me know that thank you I will no
problem thank you uh will you be taking
questions from the committee uh yes are
there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you um next
up is uh Lucas uh cor karate corot
cotti welcome to election law I don't
believe we've seen you
before right there there we go hi my
name is Lucas corot that R uh and I'm
the president of unich Democrats uh more
importantly I am a student one that
worked to help register hundreds of
Voters over the course of the last cycle
I informed every single uh person who
gave me the time today that if they
proved residency in citizenship they
could participate in our most sacred of
institutions in many cases for the first
time in their lives though I of course
have my partisan leanings the effort to
get out the vote was not my colleagues
and I were approached by many who openly
let us know they did not support our
candidates and they were without
prejudice informed of their rights it
would have helped their cause to refuse
their inquiries forcing them to do their
own research and making it more
difficult to exercise their right to
vote but that's simply not the kind of
country I would like to live in we had a
fantastic turnout on Election Day and
though the results were not necessarily
what we had desired the will of the
people was carried out and our election
was safe and secure
no Caravans of illegals migrants arrived
in Durham No Buses of Massachusetts
voters show it up to the polls what did
happen was that thousands of unh voters
uh students legally voted for the
candidates of their choosing in our case
voting for The Republican candidates at
a higher rate than the preceding
elections they did so overwhelmingly by
using their University issued student ID
card which nearly all of us carry in our
pockets at all times though my fellow
Democrats and I plan to work hard to
reverse the growing Republic base at UNH
I proudly stand against any measure to
impede their right to vote our country
was built off those who shunned the
pursuit of power for selfless gain I
understand the logic there's a group of
Voters who lean left and a right-wing
majority knows it would be to their
benefit to disenfranchise as many of
those voters as
possible I simply ask you graciously to
reject this calculus and to let the will
of the people and the UNH voters be done
thank you thank you and you had 5
seconds left cuz you know you haven't
been watching I like the competition see
who can get closest so you got pretty
close uh will you be taking questions
from the committee um are there
questions from the committee yes
representative weie thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question you
mentioned that you uh always carry your
student ID why is that well uh you can't
use the public trans uh Transit uh on
those uh it's how we access our meal
plans um fingerprints are also used as a
a biometric uh but I mean I have it in
my wallet right now I don't go anywhere
without
it
followup uh so so that gives you the
Privileges and the rights to use the
things that are being granted to you by
the University of New Hampshire would
not the same principles apply for voting
with an ID
card uh I think that uh there's
certainly discussion for private
universities if it was a St ansam issued
ID it's different than something issued
by the university system of New
Hampshire uh but that's not the bill
being discussed today
sir further questions from the committee
representative Howard thank you for
taking my question are these uh ID cards
used to G an entry into uh residency
buildings press that button again just
say absolutely again there you go yeah
yeah yeah there you go it's you're smart
to try to turn it off every time because
you'll end up like hot miking yourself
like I do all the time um further
questions from the committee uh yes
representative Lane uh thank you for
taking my question you use this ID only
to identify yourself when you vote is
that
correct
uh it's part of uh uh the process too
it's obviously on the side of proving
residency um and my main point against
is that uh you know there's been zero
cases of voter fraud when it comes to
these student ID cards and uh it's by
far the most
convenient further questions from the
committee representative
toner thank you um does a student ID
identify whether you're out of State
student uh but that's where uh residency
specifically in durm and being on the
voter roles uh comes into play it's not
the end all be all it's it's part of the
process further questions from the
committee representative Howard thank
you for your taking uh another one of my
questions uh is there any like way to
figure out if there is a student uh
living on
campus yeah absolutely uh the UN system
has uh Records evolve that and uh I
assume they're crosschecked I follow up
followup yeah uh is that access ible
online via the uh un web
portal I believe so representative thank
you appreciate it further questions
represent ton you want to turn your mic
off for uh you make yourself famous um
any other questions from the committee
um I have some can you use a uh un
student ID to board an
airplane uh it has not been tried to my
awareness sir okay uh and a followup can
you use a UNH to purchase a
firearm no sir not to my awareness okay
thank you representative uh merad I
don't know why I just blanked on your
name oh my God known you for five years
and my brain just went
no uh thank you for taking my question
did you know that moderators are
permitted to accept any legitimate ID in
order to prove identity when a voter
preent presents themselves to the
polls uh I did not sir I'll say in my
uh time working on the campaign um there
there was quite a lot of confusion on
exactly what uh proper ID uh uh entailed
and I know that there were several
stories from the polls where uh somebody
was only able to vote because they
didn't realize that they could use their
student ID um follow up from Mirad did
you know that the for instance the
moderator in NASA would be permitted to
accept a Sanders um employment
identification as proof of
identification when a voter PR presents
themselves to the
polls uh no uh but I mean I'm I'm sure
I'm not the one asking questions here uh
but uh is that exactly uh what this bill
is looking to address I believe the
topic was student
IDs thank you further questions from the
committee all right seeing N I think
we'll let the uh uh the gentleman go
thank you for entertaining us great job
by the way great job uh rep uh
tantarelli from the League of Women
Voters it's
289 okay all right hold on before we do
this because my Des is going to end up
completely trashed again can we take
that written testimony and put it right
there on the end of this table and then
members can grab it unless it's unless
they is this a copy of your written
testimony um so I'm going to leave that
there and then members can grab it on
their way out cuz what happens is my
desk at the end of this is looks like a
paper mill um so we'll leave that there
members can grab it on the way out and
that'll be unless there's something that
that you need for the testimony like you
have a graph or something like that
obviously we need that but if there's
written if it's a copywritten testimony
we'll leave that there and that way the
clerk can easily get a copy of it and
it'll make her life better and she won't
be so angry at me as my paper just takes
over the whole desk I don't get angry I
can see it I can see you get angry see
thank you that sounds like a very good
plan chairman
Barry I'm Liz torelli I'm president of
the nonpartisan League of Women Voters
of New Hampshire and as you might assume
I am opposed to this bill we've already
you've already heard testimony about how
important student IDs are to students
who carry them with them all the time
but I want to talk about older voters
this bill also gets rid of the exist
exemption in terms of expired driver's
licenses or passports that has applied
to people over
65 in 2012 when this legislature passed
the voter ID law it wisely realized that
at some point people are old enough that
they don't renew their driver's licenses
they no longer travel abroad they don't
renew their passports and you allowed
those people to use an ID that was
expired without any time frame so it
could be more than five years it is on
behalf of those people that I'm speaking
today and say please don't expect
somebody who is over 75 to have to get
to the DMV to get a non-driver ID which
will itself
expire and then they have to do it again
when they are 80
uh you're not try you you have no reason
to try to disenfranchise older voters
this bill would do that in effect so I
urge you to vote in expedient to
legislate on this bill I'd be glad to
take questions if there are any are
there any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you I'm sorry I saw represent I saw a
movement from representative Newsome the
blur um all right uh next up is Kaylee
estadio did I get
it um thank you chairman Barry and
members of the committee my name is Kaye
of stadio I a Durham voter in public
policy fellow with open democracy we're
a nonpartisan nonprofit representing
36,000 voters across the state and I'm
testimony submitting testimony today and
vment opposition to HB 684 this bill
seeks to further restrict the right of
students by rolling back well
established forms of ID out of the 36
states that currently have some form of
voter IDs in place only 12 do not allow
some form of student ID to serve as a
valid voter ID as allowing student ID to
serve as voter ID has yet to result in
any egregious case of Fraud and only
work to increase the high levels of
civic participation New Hampshire Prides
itself on I wonder the true intent
behind the bill in the wake of HB 1569
which will already work to strip
countless college students of the their
right to vote I see no compelling reason
to pass this bill when will when will
the restrictions be enough will we have
to endure drastic drops in the levels of
Youth participation in elections before
finally saying enough is enough
additionally I argue that HB 684 would
violate article 11 of the New Hampshire
Constitution which ensures that quote
every inhabitant of the state of 18
years of age and upwards shall have an
equal right to vote in any election this
bill singles out young people in a
blatant attempt to disenfranchise them
according to the Brennan Center an
estimated 18% of citizens aged 18 to 24
do not have state issued photo ID
student IDs are given to nearly every
college student after providing proof of
their identity upon enrollment making
them a secure and convenient option for
young people please vote HB 684 an
expedient to legislate to ensure that
every elig eligible Granite stator is
able to exercise their right to vote
regardless of age thank you thank you
will you be taking questions from the
committee yes are there questions from
the committee seeing none thank you
um see
uh representative plaz of are are you in
committee right
now are you in committee though right is
your committee meeting right now okay
all right we're going to finish this up
then and we'll let you introduce okay um
next up is Mackenzie Taylor and then
last one up I have is Henry ktz so um
representative
kovski um can you grab me the blue sheet
please I'm nailing the names today I've
had my coffee I'm good to go good
morning members of the committee um I'm
McKenzie Taylor um with America votes
and the New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights we are in opposition to
House Bill
684 um wanted to know that under New
Hampshire law to obtain a ballot you
need to show your proof of identity so
that's what we're talking about today
the reason we showing proof of ident
identity is to ensure the person who is
in front of you their name and photo
matches how they are registered um that
this is not showing domicile is not
showing where they live it is showing
that they are who they say they are and
that's why there is a very broad list of
acceptable IDs that are government
issued like college IDs from the major
universities um who you know can show
that the person who is standing in front
of you to get their ballot is who they
say they are and by limiting that list
it does not you know change it does not
help anyone uh make sure that we are
having folks show who they are in order
to vote uh I also wanted to mention as a
previous um person testified that we
have major concerns about the um
limiting the use of expired IDs um for
folks who are over 75 especially I know
through doing election Protection work
um with the New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights we have in multiple
occasions helped voters who didn't think
that they had an acceptable ID because
they didn't know that they were able to
use one that had been expired if they
were over a certain age so by reducing
removing that um provision as well or a
potential of totally removing people's
right to be able to cast their ballot as
seniors because they are not renewing
their licenses or passports um if
they're no longer driving or traveling
so and I'm happy to take any questions
questions from the committee
representative
toner so it's been a wee bit of time
since I've been in school but does does
a student ID now have an expiration date
on it or or does it have any type of
date of when issued or I believe the
student IDs now do have um a date on
them and that was part of and Henry is
testifying after me he might have better
idea that was part of having this be um
a way that you could show your identity
in order to register
about further questions from the
committee represent
Lane thank you for taking my question um
are you aware of any student or senior
who's been found guilty of voter fraud
by using an an ID other than what this
bill wants to use I am not thank you
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um we did have a
late entry here so my apologies um
Gan Barnes I'm I having trouble reading
it sorry I'm
conquered can you just uh when you can
you say your last name for me when you
get up here just so I can Barnes oh okay
I did read it right all right welcome to
election I don't believe we've met
before thank you good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Jean Barnes I've been a
moderator and conquered for 30 years I
worked at the post for 35
years I I want to answer just two
questions number one yes a student's
idea is accepted at the airport I used
to travel with my
granddaughter but when you're young even
6th 7th 8th 9th 10th grade there's no
other identification for you so yes it
was accepted number two as a moderator
is someone walked in with an ID from
conquered hospital or conquered High yes
I would accept it as their ID their
photo was on it their signature is on it
I worked for the state for 34 years my
ID was my picture and my signature and
the fact that I worked at the Department
of Health and Human Services I'll be
happy to answer any
questionss further questions from the F
questions from the commit not further
questions uh represent
uh thank you Miss Barnes Miss Barnes is
my moderator so um so and I can she runs
it like a she is very strict so you you
mentioned what about New Hampshire Tech
are you aware of any students from NH
the TAC um that present IDs I don't know
if I specifically have a tech but I
would take Franklin Pierce I would take
the law school I would take yes any what
I look for is their picture
and their
signature but I'm rarely called to
identify anyone my the St the crew I
call them W two crew they know what the
laws and rules are they know what we'll
accept if you have an idea and it
doesn't have your picture no we would
not accept that but we want your picture
and your
signature if you're a new registration
that day we'll take that ID but you also
have proof of
domicile thank
you okay further questions from the
committee none thank you last up is
Henry Clemen
totz thank you and good morning my name
is Henry clemento I'm the deputy legal
director of the ACLU of New Hampshire we
oppose HP
um when a person is presenting ID when
they're voting as a previous speaker
said all they're doing is proving their
identity they're not proving domicile is
that um
qualification was proven when they
registered to vote and so the point of
showing an ID is not to have your
address on it or to prove that you live
in town or that you're an instate
student it's so that the moderator or
election official can verify that you
are the person whose name appears on the
checklist that's that's the only purpose
and so what this bill does is just
simply reduce the number of
identifications to less than what the
TSA accepts um for people getting on
airplanes so for example TSA allow
allows you to uh present a driver's
license that's been expired for up to a
year I know this because I frequently
lose my driver's license uh you can
present a armed services card to get on
an airplane you can present a veterans
health insurance card to get on an
airplane types of identification that
would not be allowed now under this bill
um in addition there's actually a
process at TSA I learned uh if you don't
have any ID they can still ask you some
questions to verify your identity so you
don't actually even need a driver's
license to get on a plane or any photo
ID at all
um uh and so I'm unaware you know we
check in with the Attorney General's
office election law unit frequently I'm
unaware of any single case in which
identity fraud was the basis of a voter
fraud prosecution typically what we see
is double voting which is the type of
thing where someone owns property in two
places and votes in two places that's
not going to be stopped by this bill the
only thing that would be stopped by this
bill is someone trying to vote using
another person student ID but there's no
reason to think that student IDs are any
less secure than any other governmental
issued ID especially student IDs that
are issued by the University of New
Hampshire which is the government so I'm
happy to take any questions if there are
questions from the committee
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question I did I
hear you correctly that you said that
the act of registration for voting in uh
proves intent to
domicile um I'm not sure if I said that
but that is true
um domicile is in part a subjective
state it involves uh a place being your
Civic home for the purposes of govern
participation in governmental s in
Democratic self-government and so the
act of registering to vote is part of
the Declaration of domicile process but
what I was trying to say is that
domicile is established anden when
registering to vote in New Hampshire and
not when
voting any further questions from the
seeing
none I think representative
W um thank you Mr chair
um so if if they're registering to and
that's showing intent to domicile then
they have to comply with all the other
requirements for residency correct yes
okay thank you further questions from
the committee seeing none thank you um I
don't have any other pink cards in my
possession does anyone else wish to
speak
uh seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing
on uh good Lord six house B 684 uh resi
since you're a guy can you change out
the sign they gave us signs now so that
people watching can know what we're
on um yeah we're fancy I didn't know we
get fancy like that um I'm going to open
up the public hearing for House Bill
323 um
oh I apologize I do have the stats
online I actually have them pulled up
already uh the blue sheet good Lord man
uh blue sheet uh was zero in favor five
five zero in favor five against and then
online was 59 support 781 opposed and
two neutral all right with that I will
close the public hearing for uh 684 and
thank you for the gentle reminder um and
representative are you ready to
introduce um House Bill 323 require the
presentation of government issued
photographic means of identification
order to
vote represent me Farland after you get
done presenting can you please fill out
a pink card for us oh thank you never
mind you got it ready to go go
awesome welcome back to election law
thank you Mr
chairman good morning Mr chairman
honorable members I'm representative
Donald McFarland from Orange and I thank
you for the opportunity to introduce
House Bill 323 this testimony represents
My Views and the views and interests of
my constituents in graft and 18 my
testimony is not made on behalf of any
private employer nor should it be
construed to represent the views of any
of my employers I come before you today
to introduce and voice my strong support
for House Bill 323 which seeks
to strengthen the Integrity of New
Hampshire's elections by ensuring that
all voters present uh all voters present
uh government issued photographic
identification when casting a ballot New
Hampshire has long been recognized for
its commitment to fair and transparent
elections House Bill 323 Builds on that
Foundation by closing gaps in our voter
verification process ensuring that each
vote cast is legitimate and that our
elections remain secure reliable and
free from fraud the vast majority of
States already require voter ID and
polling consistently shows that
Americans across party lines support
these ID requirements as a common sense
safeguard for our democracy for example
I would cite a St Anon poll surveying
New Hampshire voters attitudes in which
over three quarters of respondents
considered that voters should be
required to show a photographic ID
before being allowed to cast a ballot
here in New Hampshire
and only 19% of respondents disagreed
with this view these results correspond
well to the commentary and feedback that
I have heard from my own constituents
who rightly or wrongly perceive that
there is continuing voter fraud here in
New Hampshire indeed only last night one
of my constituents described to me such
a circumstance this bill is not about
restricting access to The Ballot Box it
is about ensuring confidence in the
process for those who may not currently
possess a satisfactory ID the state will
continue to assist in providing one at
no cost to ensure that every eligible
voter has the ability to comply with
this requirement the fundamental right
to vote is the Cornerstone of our
democracy House Bill 323 ensures that
every legal vote counts while preventing
fraudulent or erroneous ballots from
diluting the voice of legitimate voters
I urge the committee to pass this bill
and reaffirm our commitment to election
Integrity here in New Hampshire thank
you your time in consideration and I'm
happy to take any questions other
questions from the committee
representative
Ward thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question
could you just reiterate for us what the
purpose of showing a photo ID to a
moderator or ballot inspector is from my
point of view the purpose is clear first
of all it demonstrates to the ballot
clerk that you are the same individual
that is listed on the checklist and that
has already demonstrated citizenship and
so forth to the uh the supervisors of
the checklist and second of all in so
doing it maintains confidence in this
the Integrity of the voting process as I
was
outlining further questions for the
committee representative Mirad thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question of course do you think sir that
a an a photo ID issued by an employer um
might suffice to prove identity might
suffice to prove that the person
presenting themselves to the ballot
clerk is the person that they say they
are I don't think that there's any
identity that could be provided that
would prove identity my understanding is
that there have been some very clever
people uh from time to time who who
managed to forge all kinds of documents
the question at hand is what is an
appropriate level of confidence in that
identity for our New Hampshire election
process and what I've learned La out in
this bill I think reflects that I don't
believe that it would be appropriate to
take some random employers photo ID uh
from you know a private employer in the
state or even uh for certain public
employeers in the state because the
reality is that in the the towns uh and
Wards of our state it is highly unlikely
that all of the election staff are going
to be familiar with all of the different
IDs you know that that are presented by
uh these different private employers and
it's not even clear that those private
employers would have the necessary
Security checks and safeguards built
into those IDs so I I think if we're
going to be respectful of our election
employees uh and of the the the
volunteers in the towns who are Staffing
the election process we need to give
them clear guidelines and I think giving
them the guidelines that they should be
able to accept the the several different
identity documents that are still
uh able to be used if this bill passes I
think that gives them enough Clarity and
it allows the Secretary of State to to
give them examples of all those
documents further questions from the
committee representative uh
Wei thank you Mr chair and thank you
represent parl for taking my question
the um I believe the RSA has other um
instances where government issued IDs
are required do you know off hand how
many times that is mentioned or required
uh you you're asking about how many
times in in our entire rsas we mentioned
the requirement for government ID off
the top of my head I don't I I will say
however um that I'm aware that in order
to drive in the state you require a
driver's license to be issued uh by the
state after a period of time living in
the state and and certainly uh you need
to have uh a satisfactory driver's
license uh in order to drive um and I
believe that the same is true uh the
chairman was asking uh on the prior bill
about the requirement to fly uh and I
think that the requirement to fly
frankly is even more onerous uh by a
substantial margin than what I'm
proposing here in this
bill further questions from the
committee representative
Lane uh thank you and thank you for
taking my question um you mentioned that
the purpose one of the purposes of this
bill was to provide uh
confidence uh in the voting process are
you aware that both the governor
our prior governor and not our current
governor governor sununu and the
Secretary of State have expressed
confidence in our
existing system and which includes
trusting the
moderators to do their jobs and do them
well I'm aware that that Governor sununu
has said many things uh and I'm aware
that for that matter I have expressed
confidence in our election process uh
historically the fact that I have an
adequate degree of confidence does not
mean that I think it is perfect and I
think that some of the the concerns that
are expressed to me by my constituents
are ones that are ostensibly reasonable
and that this bill can satisfy and I
would put to you that if we look at the
November general election there were
about 833 th000 voters who cast their
ballot in that election and of those
only three people
did not bring their IDs to the poll and
were able to satisfy that that they in
fact uh were those people uh we are now
in a circumstance where those three
people out of 833 th000 are going to
need to remember to drive home and get
their driver's license or their voter
identification card that they probably
should have had when they got in the car
in the first
place further question from the commit
representative
Bay thank you Mr Barry uh thank you
thank you for taking my question um
would a global entry ID uh satisfy this
uh requirement for um government issued
photographic means from my point of view
uh I think that it is a very reasonable
question let me just before I give you a
straight answer let me just review the
text because what I will tell you is
that um I was going back and forth at
the end of the year with OS on getting
my bills drafted they were not drafted
as as quickly as I might have hoped and
so I I will admit that the language of
this is not exactly what I would have
wanted so let me answer your question in
two ways
representative first of all uh the
language does support using a United
States armed services identification
card a federal driver's license a
passport a passcard it does not mention
a global entry card and I think there's
a a fair question as to would a global
entry card be sufficient I think it
comes back to question around uh as we
broaden the number of different identity
cards and and documents that the the
local officials are going to need to
support how many of those people are
familiar with those cards how many of
those people know what to check for on
those cards and I do think at one level
uh that what is in here is is a more
than ample set of documents the second
thing I'll say to my point about the
nature of the language is that I did
strike uh in lines uh 7 through 12 the
section about recording the state of
issuance of out of state licenses and
non- drivers ID cards and so forth and
that that was struck for me by by the
the OS in the drafting but what I would
suggest to the committee is that it
would be appropriate to add back in not
that exact language but add back in
language for the less than 63-day
circumstance of that new voter on the
checklist to make sure that we have not
only the state of issuance but enough
specificity around what id they've
presented that audits can be
performed further questions from the
committee representative
Wilhelm thank you chairman and
representative thanks for taking my
question um what's the nearest how long
does it take for you to get to your
closest DMV from
Orange uh about 10 minutes for me to
drive to my town clerk who is the local
agent of the DMV thank
you 10 minutes
representative P
O'Brien thank you so um as I read this
you could still reg you could still
register to vote that on the day of the
election as and if you if you did not
have a New Hampshire license is this
correct if as long as things matched up
as long as the state that you're
declaring that you just previously voted
in matched up with the state issued
license thank you for your question
representative I understand let me just
add to to representative Wilhelm uh it
takes me about 15 minutes to drive to
the local gas station so you know
there's that um
the yeah the the question that you posed
uh this bill is not seeking to change
one aota of the registration process
this bill is purely seeking to attend to
the process when somebody who's already
on the checklist presents identification
to vote and so you know while I
certainly have opinions about the
registration process I don't think
that's Jermain to this
bill further questions from the
committee represent Newsome thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
of those 830,000 voters you cited how
many used a fraudulent student
ID how would I know that thank
you were there any cases you got to do a
followup or right yeah you can say
followup I say yes and then sorry are
you aware of any I'm aware that I have a
lot of constituents who have significant
concerns about the voting process
precisely because we don't have
satisfactory mechanisms in place right
now to disprove that there was
significant student
fraud I turn myself off further
questions from the committee saying none
thank you um next up is thank you Mr
chairman Nico uh
derazio awesome uh from Handover
thank you Mr chairman I'm sorry I'm
sorry beatric Barack I apologize I
didn't see the second name my apologies
yes we'll testify together if that's all
right that's totally fine wonderful
thank
you good morning we'd like to thank
chairman Barry and the members of the
committee for the opportunity to testify
uh in opposition to House Bill
323 my name is beatric Buck I'm a senior
at Dartmouth College
and my name is Nico derazio and I'm
proudly a freshman at Dartmouth
College nio and I are both part of
Dartmouth Civics which is a nonpartisan
organization committed to helping
Handover community members and Dartmouth
students exercise our constitutional
right to vote we oppose House Bill 323
because it would unnecessarily burden
student voters and town officials over
complicating a process that is currently
functioning like a well-oiled machine in
Handover I was born and raised in
hopkington New Hampshire to parents who
always took me with them to town meeting
and the polls but when I came to
Dartmouth I met many students who didn't
have the same exposure to the Civic
process my friend and I founded
Dartmouth Civics after the 2022 midterm
elections because we saw that many of
our classmates were intimidated by the
complexity of the voting process and
there was insufficient coordination
between Town officials and students on
voting related matters
Dartmouth Civics fills those gaps by
providing resources and information to
help students and community members vote
and engage in Civic processes we have
spent over 300 hours sitting at a table
in the student center to answer
questions about voting well ahead of
every election each election season we
create and distribute hundreds of
pamphlets of nonpartisan voter
information triple checked by college
and town officials
we also host public events that are open
to the community uh we host candidate
forums where hand Handover residents can
come here from candidates for local
office Every Spring uh this fall we
hosted the chairs of the New Hampshire
Democratic and Republican parties on
campus to inform students about their
respective parties
platforms we support all eligible
student voters in their efforts to vote
that's regardless of their party
affiliation and regardless of if they
choose to vote in their hometowns in
another state or or here in
Handover we are incredibly proud of the
strong relationships we've built with
Hanover's town clerk Town manager and
supervisors of the checklist we seek to
reduce the administrative burdens on
them by making the requirements for
registration and voting clear of
students and community members we
frequently receive messages of gratitude
from town officials who appreciate that
since we began our efforts many more
students have been arriving at Town Hall
and the polls early with the necessary
documentation in Dartmouth civic's
experience students come to Dartmouth
excited to vote and to be engaged
members of the Handover Community my
friend Nico here is a great
example members of the committee I am
sure you remember your first time voting
and shared the same excitement I had
when I voted last year when I arrived on
dartmouth's campus I eagerly looked
forward to voting in My First Federal
Election
but tant Mount to that I could not wait
to vote and down ballot New Hampshire
elections as well I spent hours
researching our states candidates
because it was important to me that I
had the opportunity to shape the world
around me after all this is my home for
the next four years and maybe more
Dartmouth Civics taught me the process
of voting in New Hampshire so I was able
to take all of my documents to town hall
to register well in advance of the
election I was surprised by how secure
and orderly the registration process was
however there were quite a few documents
to remember so when election day rolled
around I was glad to be able to vote by
just presenting my Dartmouth ID which
has my photo and verification and an XY
reate this process worked seamlessly for
me and my fellow students and I know
that it was based on reliable precedent
from that New Hampshire has supported
for many years changing our voger ID
laws will only complicate the orderly
process that New Hampshire already has
all right I'm going to have to ask you
guys to conclude your marks I did give
you an extra two minutes because there's
two of you so we got to bring her to a
conclusion great thank you I'm wrapping
up voting is our civic duty as American
citizens and it's also our
constitutionally protected right
Dartmouth Civics and our partners in the
town of Hanover have been working hard
to ensure that all members of our
community feel empowered to participate
in that process the process is working
well and there is no need for the
DraStic change that hb32 would
bring it is for these reasons that as
members of Dartmouth Civics we urge you
to oppose this bill we thank you for
your time and consideration all right
will you be taking questions from the
committee we will are there questions
from the
committee um I I have one who is your
favorite Dartmouth college
professor and we are we will need an
answer and and you're not you know I
can't say you're under oath but you know
imagine you're under
oath you know I've never taken one of
Professor Mirad classes but I know he's
offering one this spring so I'm thinking
about it oh yeah thinking about it heard
she's only a
senior thank you I would have to Echo
that same opinion
oh very very political thank you so much
U next up is David Trumble from my town
of wear
uh thank you Mr uh chairman and
committee members my name is David
Trumble from the town of wear I oppose
this bill because I believe that
students should be able to freely
exercise their constitutional right to
vote as far as I can tell there's only
been one US Supreme Court case that has
addressed this subject it was Sim versus
the United States and they did affirm
that college students have the
constitutional right to register and
vote where they attend college New
Hampshire also there may be others but
the only most recent one I can find is
the case of legue of Women Voters in the
Democratic party versus Secretary of
State the court said that voting is the
most fundamental significance under our
constitutional structure other rights
even the most basic are a loser if the
right to vote is undermined and they
cited the New Hampshire Constitution all
elections are to be free and every
inhabitant of the state of 18 years of
age and upwards shall have an equal
right to vote in any election and they
say where has domicile and that was a
case specific to the issue of
students um couple things about students
I've worked at of New Hampshire college
for over 40 years so I do speak with
just no some knowledge of it on on the
ground two things one is that students
are active members of their communities
they live in the area where they go to
school for at least 8 to nine months a
year which is certainly longer than our
six months plus one day snowbirds they
work in the community whether it's doing
child care or substitute teach teaching
or working in the local sub shop and
they volunteer and do internships with
everything from media to government and
everything businesses in between so
they're active members of our community
they're not just passively sitting in
their dorm room for nine months they're
affected by what happens the other thing
is that they are directly affected by
local and state issues four examples
first is money property taxes is how we
Finance everything that affects the rent
that they pay we have $7 minimum wage
that affects the amount of money that
they can earn at their jobs second is
social issues whether you're a liberal
or a conservative and your concerns are
lgbtq rights or access to abortion or
religious freedom the laws that you pass
affect them Health in the environment
energy policy in the state affects clean
air and clean water and lastly labor
laws there was a bill before the Senate
Commerce Committee last year that dealt
directly with the rights of Ra's
resident assistance at colleges these
students have a constitutional right to
vote they're directly affected by the
decisions that you make and their active
members of Community we should not do
anything we can to discourage their
voting oh one last thing I forgot which
is that you need you to bring your
remarks to conclusion so the last thing
is we want to encourage people to
participate in their democracy if you
vote at the age of 18 you're going to be
a lifelong voter we shouldn't discourage
people from voting when they're young
thank you right will you be taking
questions from the committee uh yes Mr
chairman uh are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you uh next
up is Kaylee Kaylee esto um and then
after that we have one more McKenzie
Taylor so res gasi can you grab the blue
sheet for me start wrapping this up and
the reason we haven't started 289 is 289
is sponsored by a Committee Member so we
don't need to jump the gun
yet um thank you chairman Barry and
members of the House committee my name
is kayy of stadio I'm a Durham voter and
public policy fell with open democracy
and I'm testifying in opposition to HB
323 this bill provides an extremely
narrow definition of governmen issued
photo ID excluding both outof state
driver licenses and student ID cards
these are two measures that indicate a
sense of fear in the legislature
regarding the power of student voting in
2016 current Senator Maggie Hassen be
incumbent Kelly aot by just 1,7 votes
meaning a single class of Dartmouth
students alone could have made the
difference you cannot without compelling
Rhyme or Reason roll back such an unpro
statute this bill seeks to craft a
solution for potential fraud that
seemingly has not and may not ever be
occur Beyond its current minuscule rates
rates that might I add are certainly not
spearheaded by college students but by
those who own second homes or are moving
between towns in New Hampshire when
talking when talking about
disenfranchising an entire age group I
think you have to be certain as an out
ofate voter myself domiciled in New
Hampshire as I obtained my masters from
UNH I can't see any reason why I
shouldn't retain the right to cast my
vote where I spend the majority of my
time for the past 5 years I have spent
10 months out of the year in New
Hampshire and and just two in
Massachusetts as many College college
students tend to I have come to love my
new environment and plan to move here
permanently after
graduation however even this intent
should not be required the sheer fact
that out of state college students are
counted in the US Census at their
respective schools where they live and
sleep most of the time as opposed to
their home state should be common sense
reason enough additionally in lines 15
through 23 of the bill there are
exceptions made for voting with an out
ofate ID for those who have been on the
voter checklist fewer than 63 days if
the goal of this bill is to make it
harder for both in and out of state
students to vote which I presume it is
then this exception provides ample time
for out of state students to join the
checklist just before an election and
vote so even from a pro voter
restriction standpoint I feel that HB
323 is not ready for prime time please
vote HB 323 and expedient to legislate
to ensure the rights of many are not
needlessly cast aside
I accidentally shut you off I apologize
I pressed I pressed the left button
instead of the right button I'm sorry
that was not that was not intentional
that was a never uh as I said never
attribute to malice what can be
attributed to uh to incompetence so um
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you and I do
apologize about that it was really not I
really feel bad about that last up is
Mackenzie Taylor
good morning and members of the
committee Mackenzie Taylor with America
votes in the New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights I'm like to start with a
reminder that there is no evidence of
voter fraud or wise voter fraud in New
Hampshire and that we do have what is
considered a strict voter ID law in New
Hampshire because when you go to obtain
a ballot you are required now to have an
ID that has your name and photo on it um
so what this bill will do uh by reducing
the number of IDs that you can use is uh
limit access to The Ballot Box for
voters because folks can be turned away
simply because uh that they have the
wrong kind of ID not in even that they
don't have an ID at all um again the
purpose of showing an ID when you check
in is to prove who you say you are with
your name and matching name and photo it
is not to prove where you live um or
your domicile that is a different
barrier of proof that you do when you
register to vote um and this bill
removes you not only IDs from States
outside of New Hampshire and college IDs
but also public high school IDs so for
students and there's more and more of
them who turn 18 are looking to vote for
the first time but are not drivers um it
also removes those um the ability for
those folks to use that ID to vote often
I voted my first time when I was at my
high school as a high school student um
and those folks could no longer use
their uh student ID for that reason um
finally I know I was mentioned that you
can get um a free voter ID for folks who
don't have other IDs in State this is
true but folks do need to go to the DMV
which I believe I just looked it up
there are 12 locations across the state
um and it's a multi-step process of
going to a clerk's office and then a DMV
um and for someone who potentially
doesn't drive and they don't have a
license which is why they're getting one
um that can be a high barrier so the
only outcome of this bill is likely that
more folks will be turned away um from
voting the polls and turning away folks
from voting um actually reduces voter
confidence instead of increases it um
and with that I am happy to take any
questions questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um on the blue
sheet we had no in favor five against on
yes sorry did I miss your
card sure
yeah just go ahead and uh say your name
and when you get done fill out a pink
card and send it up to me please Jee
Barn moderator award to and conquered
I'm a post this bill something just
occurred to me in order for your name to
be on a checklist you have to fill out a
registration form which gives your name
your address your driver's license or
your passport it also requires you to
declare if you're a citizen of the
United States you have to sign it and
the moderator supervisor of the
checklist or elected official has to
sign it there's one other point I'd like
to make on Election Day a lot of people
have to stand outside in the cold
sometimes the rain sometimes the Sate
Hill sum are heat although we don't have
elections in summer they just want to
come in prove their identity receive a
ballot and a pencil go into the boing
Place vote then put their ballot in the
black box that's all they want to do a
lot of times it takes less than the
required time but you have to keep the
voters in mind when you look at these
bills and don't restrict their right to
vote thank you hey will you be taking
questions from the committee sure okay
seeing none thank you all right back to
wrapping this bill up here um I already
read the blue sheet and then online so I
don't forget again we're on 323 yeah uh
48 in support 735 in opposition zero
neutral and with that I will close the
uh public hearing on House Bill 3 23 and
I will open the H I will open the public
hearing on House Bill 289 uh relative
regarding domicile qualifications for
voting repres recognize repres our own
representative wey for the purpose of
introduction thank you Mr chair and
honorable committee members for the
record my name is Robert wor and I have
the privilege of representing Hillsboro
District 13 great town of Hudson I start
off with an apology because I'll be
speaking a little longer than normal but
this is to provide some background
behind the modest changes this bill
makes to the existing
RSA um by way of introduction just nine
days ago we celebrated Groundhog's Day
when Puck Satani Phil joined the
plethora of weather forecasters and
attempted to forecast how long our
winter would last there was even a
famous movie some years ago Groundhog
Day starring Bill Murray why bring up
this movie because for 18 months for a
full year and a half I was the man in
the plant at a manufacturing facility in
Woodstock Illinois Woodstock just
happens to be the location where much of
that film was shot and I met several of
the uh Woodstock movie extras who
appeared in that film while all this
Preamble well I spent an extended period
of time in Woodstock some might say I
was domiciled there but not really I
didn't pay for my housing nor much of my
food nor for my transportation to from
and around Woodstock in other words I
was dependent to my employer to supply
these basic needs I filled out expense
reports and was reimbursed by the
company for these expenses to the best
my recollection I voted by absentee
ballot in another state where I rented
an apartment and that apartment address
was used for all the appropriate W2 and
other IRS tax forms in thinking about my
own history it occurred to me that there
might be others who are temporarily
living in New Hampshire and who are
temporar and who are dependents temporal
temp sorry I'm having trouble saying
that word um temporarily absent from
their primary residence the IRS IGN
acknowledges such cases and notes in IRS
publication 501 that there are
dependants who are temporarily absent
from their primary address for the
purposes of illness education business
vacation military service or detention
in a juvenile facility it includes an
assumption that the dependent will
return home after the temporary absence
so here we have a conundrum if a
dependent claims to have a domicile here
in New Hampshire and votes here for the
federal tax requirements they are
stating that they do not intend to
return home but rather to stay in New
Hampshire if that is true if they are
emancipated from the person supporting
them and they are paying their own way
now then the person who continues to
list that dependent on the federal tax
form is breaking federal tax law on the
other hand if the custodian or guardian
or parent of the dependent has a
legitimate legitimate federal tax claim
for the dependent then the dependent is
committing blatant voter fraud
being the conscientious person that I am
and wanting to look out for others I do
not want dependents or the person
supporting them to be in any sort of
legal bind so the changes in section one
are offered for
clarification House Bill 289 also
provides changes to section 1A currently
the University of system of New
Hampshire has affidavit requirements for
instate tuition RSA 187a colon 16
subsection 18 allows for a differential
rate intuition to be charged for instate
versus outof State students subsection
23 allows for those receiving the
instate tuition to execute an affidavit
in order to obtain those instate tuition
rates one example of the affidavit form
entitled residency statement for New
Hampshire residents was provided on the
University website and several sections
of this form are knowed for
consideration at the top of the form it
states this form is only for those who
have established a legal residency in
New Hampshire at least 12 months or more
not focusing on the 12 months but
focusing on the legal residency my
apologies chair Mr chair um it goes on
and it it talks about um eligibility for
instate
tuition and States explicitly if you are
domiciled in New Hampshire that means
New Hampshire must be your true fixed
and permanent home and place of
habitation to the exclusion of all other
places and it go on it goes on that form
does goes on to state that dependent
students and explains that um they must
be able to claim dependency Upon A New
Hampshire resident parents federal tax
forms so the University of system of New
Hampshire affidavit requires legal
residency an intent to remain in New
Hampshire in compliance with applicable
federal tax laws this bill makes the
residency requirements for students
voting in New Hampshire overtly
consistent with the residency requires
requirements specified in the applicable
RSA and administrative rules provided by
the university system of New Hampshire
finally in the last section section 1B
it's a new section that says intent to
maintain a single continuous presence
can be defined by a driver's license and
by instate Motor Vehicle Registration
there is a provisor for non-resident
voter ve motor vehicle registration but
that is under 20
26146 as opposed to uh
26145 and those people who have um such
a registration as non-residents would
not be eligible to vote so I would be
glad to answer any questions and I thank
the committee for their patience in
listening to this questions from the
committee representative
Nome thank you very much and thanks for
taking my question um in regards to the
changes about to increase the residency
to the 12 months per the UNH requirement
is that fall of foul of federal law
saying that residency requirements can
be capped at 30 days uh this is not uh
thank you for your question I I
appreciate that as I stated I think in
earlier in my testimony it was a long
time ago I know um but um the focus uh
for noting the uh system University
system of New Hampshire is that they
require a legal re residenc to be
established that's kind of Proviso one
and then they require the additional 12
months I'm merely saying that they have
to require that legal residency as
defined by the University of New
Hampshire not the 12 months Proviso so
not that is not the requirement there
thank you for your question further
questions from the
committee representative Howard so I'm
not sure if this is unintentional or not
but the and residency rules uh as
established by the university system of
New Hampshire the and really throws me
off so is that and
intentional uh thank you for your
question um I would have to look at my
original LSR submission and see if a
change has been made by OS but
um I um I'd be get I'll respond to that
uh later on I I'll research that and see
what I originally sent okay thank you
thank you for questions from the
committee representative Lane
uh thank you for taking my question
um are you aware that there's a
difference between domicile and legal
residency uh it's my understanding under
under both House Bill and Court
decisions that domicile and residency
are
equivalent I think we might want to
we're going to be looking at that
question later I think we will be
further questions from the Comm
seeing none thank you next up is Lauren
Banker thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Lauren Banker I have written testimony
actually I'll give up
first on the table because you yeah it's
uh it ends up being like Mount
Washington the end of the day
uh yes we do have a card thank you very
much for hearing my testimony today for
the record my name is Lauren banker and
I serve as the senior director of
government relations for the University
system of New Hampshire um I want to
speak to a few concerns that we have
with the proposed legislation um
specifically wanted to note that state
law does Grant the university system uh
of New Hampshire Board of Trustees the
authority to set policies and determine
eligibility for instate tuition rates
and at its most basic which I think I've
heard mentioned already
is the requ current requirement states
that to be eligible for instate tuition
a student or their parents must one
physically reside in the state for at
least 12 consecutive months and two must
reside in New Hampshire for some purpose
other than obtaining an education uh we
think that the proposed legislation
tying the right to vote with a residency
requirement established by a third party
in this case the university system of
New Hampshire um uh for the purpose of a
uh very different purpose in the sense
that uh it creates a tuition
differential we think that um there's
confusion there and there's hesitation
there um especially if a student at a
private New Hampshire college or
university could vote in New Hampshire
after living here for less than a year
whereas a student at a usnh institution
would not be afforded that same right um
additionally one other piece is um from
a privacy perspective instate residency
status is not a directory of information
um that we could share released to town
or city officials for voter registration
so looking at the bill um we're
specifically asking that the uh line on
line
16 page 1 16- 17 paragraph 2 um is
removed uh specifically stating and
residency rules as established by the
university system of New Hampshire and
I'm happy to take any questions further
question are there questions from the
committee representative Lane um thank
you and thank you for taking my question
so you don't have any um uh testimony
with regard to the other U on lines nine
10 and 11 I just want to be clear
correct yeah we're just here speaking
more in line with yeah thank you for
your question thank you further
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you next up is representative
Timothy Horan
just fairly just very quickly just as I
was just pointed out before from a
fiscal point that would be disaster if
the university system New Hampshire if
they had to uh well Tie The Residency
rules to voting The Residency um the
resumes rules for tuition are based on
where basically where you lived um
before you enrolled University
eligibility to vote is based on where
you're living at the time so students or
residents of uh if they they live in a
place place like Durham while going
going to school they're they're
residents they residents of Durham
they're eligible to claim the domicile
just like any other citizen so um just
in terms that's very discriminatory it
probably would not pass muster under
either the us or state constitutions and
it's uh fundamentally fundamentally
unfair and also we shouldn't voting is a
good habit good habits in adult life are
often formed while you're while you're
in college and so this is something we
should be discouraging people from doing
and I know you you can say well they can
vote absentee but then there's an attack
um on the right to absentee voting too
so absentee voting it's already not that
simple and be even less simple so I
would just say this is an unfair bill
it's unconstitutional there's uh no
reason to pursue it so I would urge you
to itl it and I'll also add in a
previous Li I worked for the Census
Bureau and one of the major things
we do during the denial census is sort
out all the duplicate entries from uh
young people who are um enumerated at
their college dorm or other uh residents
near College and who are Mist counted at
their parents house quote unquote back
home and actually it's a record for the
person from a back home which is a
duplicate which needs to be taken out
and this so that's one of the major the
census peral actually goes a lot of
effort to take any college students who
are countered their parent par house out
because they are in fact not residents
of where their parents live but the
residents of where they live so I I
would urge you for many reasons to uh
itl this this peren this bill um so
thanks I'd be have to take any questions
if anybody wants them are questions from
the committee seeing none thank you oh
thank you next up is uh Lucas Kate
coratti excuse
me oh you got it the second time yeah it
I I I I realized how bad I butchered it
karate like a martial arts and
definitely not it all right you're up
welcome back oh man he wants more okay
all right the red is on there we go it
sounds like it's on anyway uh listen I
don't have a prepared statement for this
one but when I saw it on the docket I
figured I uh ought to come back up and
uh I really think it is a it's a bad
idea to uh tie the UNH system residency
uh requirements which is specifically
for instate tuition uh uh tying these
tax requirements uh and uh billing
requirements to the fundamental right to
vote and uh again it's been pointed out
that the and is uh problematic there but
the determination of domicile on the
University system website and that's uh
uh section four uh number six 6.1 I
don't know how to say that but um uh it
says uh will not be eligible unless he
has been domiciled within New Hampshire
for 12 consecutive months I don't know a
single student who is uh domiciled in uh
uh at UNH for 12 consecutive months and
if you add in that basically what you're
doing is uh uh bumping up the age to
vote at un to 19 and uh that's not even
uh counting in the folks who are at
residence halls for several years which
many of us are and the last thing is
it's a requirement at the University of
New Hampshire and uh University system
schools uh that all freshmen must be
domiciled uh on campus the first year uh
it's an exclusionary Bill uh that takes
out a huge slice of Voters and I get
that uh they tend to be partisan uh left
uh they tend to be but you know what uh
that could flip someday and I see no
reason to set a president where we cut
out a large population of young voters
uh simply because of who they tend to
vote
for will you be taking questions from
the committee oh I'll try okay all right
are there questions from the committee
representative Howard thank you for
taking my question do you see the
possibility of uh the creation of two
separate classes of Voters one uh who
ones who live in Residence halls and
ones who rent uh property nearby on on
campus well you know what uh the biggest
thing I'd point out is that uh at the
memorial Union building uh the MB we
call it at UNH uh every student has a
specific mailbox where they get mail and
their address on that governmen issued
mailbox is Durham New Hampshire uh and
uh that's not even talking about the the
folks who uh reside off of Campus who
have their own address uh you would
think everybody would be covered there
uh but it seems to be uh you know that
somebody's looking for an exclusion here
and I get it's supposed to fix a
discrepancy uh but I just don't see it
here okay thank you further questions
from committee from the committee
members represent toner you're a no one
gets asked questions like this I don't
know why they they the committee loves
you I don't know thank you um I just had
a question do you are you aware that a
PO Box does that establish residence
because that's what the Granite State uh
Square station addresses are peel box
correct uh I'm yeah I'm not sure of the
exact classification of the law uh I
don't think it's single student does uh
on campus uh but once again uh what I'm
speaking out against is uh exclusion
here due to residency on campus which is
in UN in New Hampshire where we work in
turn uh and contribute to the community
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um is the UNH
lobbyist still here did she depart she
left she left okay I had a question um
last up is Mackenzie Taylor um
representative offy can you grab the uh
blue sheet for
me good morning still morning uh members
of the committee McKenzie Taylor with
America votes and New Hampshire campaign
for voting rights um oops just step back
a second and remind folks that again the
definition of domicile for voting
purposes is where folks live and conduct
their civic life this is a definition
about the voters themselves it's not
about their relatives how they're paying
taxes about where they live in New
Hampshire and that they are conducting
their Civil Life in New Hampshire um
everyone who's voting is required to be
18 years old these are adults who are
living in New Hampshire and you know if
someone is I'm going to talk about
people were talking about living on
campus that campus address itself the
physical dorm room would be their
domicile for voters who um are claiming
that whether they you know came in and
and lived in do previously and moved to
Durham or somewhere else that room is
their domicile if that is where they're
voting in New Hampshire um we also are
opposing this bill sorry we're opposing
this bill generally um because of the
conflating domicile in New Hampshire for
voting purposes and the definition of
residency by the university system that
definition of residency is also totally
different than for saying getting a
driver's license it is much stricter it
is um a much longer term process um and
this is you know different than the
Constitutional requirement um to vote in
New Hampshire being domicile um and is
different than the process of say
getting again A New Hampshire ID moving
here and conducting your life here um
and therefore we'd be removing folks
from being able to vote generally um
because they are not meeting very
specific terms of University system
domicile um and finally I wanted to note
that that sub paragraph about students
um in the University system requirements
uh seems to not acknowledge the
existence of uh private universities so
for example St anom College those
students are able to again if they are
domiciled New Hampshire vote there um
but those are not students who are uh
you know counted as either having
instate tuition or not um because they
do not go to a public university but
have the same rights um as other voters
in New
Hampshire and I'm happy to answer any
questions
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um Le last up is
representative palazov I apologize
representative I didn't see a card from
you so I don't like to let the I don't
like to make the Reps
wait representing May Mark 10 hookit and
Dan Bon and my uh constituents asked me
to support this bill because a lot of
confusion around residency and doile is
a
relates uh to college student and this
bill will help to protect college
students but also their parents uh
because uh uh the
situation as is there was allegation
that if parents uh uh file for the New
Hampshire uh voting resident students
out of state as legal dependent that the
uh committing I L fraud so it it would
be beneficial for parents and it would
be beneficial for students uh for
clarity U where a doile and
universities uh where intellectuals are
so let's us trust the university system
of New Hampshire uh and uh the The
Residency rules uh they have already
established uh and uh uh couple of uh uh
questions so uh regarding uh the end at
line 16 uh I believe uh and is essential
for this bill to have the effect uh
intended and and line 14 already has May
so I think end is
essential uh uh there were questions
about uh 12 consecutive months uh so
Prime sponsor uh said that uh the bill
doesn't uh have it and it's not his
intention so if committee feels that we
need to put some amendment to clarify
that well consensi month so generally
like the time residency requirement is
not the intention of proposed
restriction I think uh that Amendment uh
could be made and uh uh lastly uh there
were allegations that uh this bill
affects right to vote absolutely not no
uh it just uh vote where you reside if
you are resident of another state vote
absentee in the state where you reside
thank
you yeah will you be taking questions
from the committee are there questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
thank you with that I'm going to close
the public hearing on House Bill
289 uh uh the blue sheet was Zero
support seven opposed uh signed up who
did not speak online was 47 in support
674 in opposition I'm going to close the
public hearing on 689 and I'm going to
open the public hearing on House Bill
385 FN reestablishing voter
identification exceptions and I will
recognize representative Lane for the
purpose of
introduction representative L have you
have you spoken on the have you
introduced a bill yet this year oh yeah
okay all right I was going to do the
welcome to election law but apparently
you've already apparently you've already
been welcomed my apologies last time
last week so uh for the record um I'm
representative Connie Lane and um I
represent marac District 16 which is
also ward two and
conquered um this bill repeals the now
Infamous HB
1569 which was adopted last year HB 1569
upended the voting process in New
Hampshire enacting one of the most
restrictive voting laws in the United
States no state has successfully done
what
HP HB 1569 does by requiring documentary
proof of citizenship to register to vote
without an affidavit option federal
courts have weighed in on this issue
previously determined that a similar
Kansas law which imposed a proof of
citizenship requirement for state and
federal elections violated both the US
Constitution and National voter
registration Act of
1993 the court found that the state's
interest did not outweigh the
disenfranchisement of 31,000 citizens of
that state that's how many voters were
denied um voting in an election once the
law was passed the same will be found
true here at the current lawsuit at the
end of the current lawsuit challenging a
HB
1569 lawsuit that will cost probably
cost the taxpayers millions of
dollars um I have put um a cop I tried
to put a copy online of the um original
uh filing of uh in that lawsuit in the
district court but it was so big it
wouldn't take it so I'll figure that out
later but anyway just to let you know uh
before 1569 a person uh registering to
vote who did not have certain
documentation could sign a sworn
statement at the polls to cast their
ballot but under HB 1569 that option is
removed leading to eligible voters
getting turned away at the polls and
leaving them wholly unable to vote
despite the proven accuracy reliability
and security of New Hampshire's
elections hb5 1569 introduced
fundamental changes to the state's
election law that make it materially
harder if not impossible for thousands
of New Hampshire citizens to exercise
their right to vote changes that violate
both the first and 14th amendments of
the US
Constitution HB 1569 requires
documentary proof of citizenship for
registrant such documentary proof would
require birth certificate a passport or
naturalization papers however not all
qualified individuals possess these
types of documents or keep them readily
available and obtaining them can be
expensive and time consuming it could
cost up to $100 to obtain a birth
certificate up to $600 to obtain
citizenship papers and $150 to get a
passport and all three take months to
obtain most people cannot afford these
fees
the average New Hampshire citizen does
not have enough savings to cover $400 of
unexpected fees HB 1569 also violates
the constitution in another way under
law before HB HB 1569 a prospective
voter who is already
registered but whose eligibility is
nevertheless challenged by a peer voter
um is
permitted it was permitted to cast a
challenged voter affidavit sworn under
the penalties of Fraud and perjury HB
1569 entirely removes the right to vote
by challenge voter affidavit for these
voters who have already registered and
established their right their
eligibility many of them would not have
documentary proof of Citizen with ship
citizenship with them on Election Day to
rebut a surprise challenge to their
qualifications I don't know about you
but I I don't carry my passport around
1569 was enacted despite broad skeptic
skepticism about its utility and
constitutionality when introducing the
bill to the Senate on April 23rd 2 2024
representative Lynn admitted that it was
not addressing a present problem with
voter fraud in New Hampshire stating do
I think there's a huge issue of voter
fraud in New Hampshire no I don't
because I think if I think if here if
there was here we would know it on April
30th
2024 Senator gray expressed doubts about
the constitutionality of HB 1569 stating
that he told the bill sponsor which
representative ly that I don't think
that we can withstand the court
challenge the way the bill was written
Senator gray even attempted to introduce
a similar Bill house house bill 1370 to
remedy his concerns about HB 1569
unconstitutionality but that alternative
Bill I know you want me to talk but I'm
going to keep
going but this that alternative bill was
tabled by the house at a hearing on his
proposed alternative Bill Senator gray
conceded that the New Hampshire has has
not had a problem a lot of people who
have been prosecuted for voter
fraud at a committee of conference
Senator scanland recognized the the
burdens that 1569 put on
citizens in his testimony he estimated
that removing the qualified voter
affidavit for citizenship would affect
tens of thousands of Voters who could
not otherwise be quickly verified as
being previously registered through the
centralized voter
database I urge you to repeal 1569
before our state spends millions of
dollars on legal fees to defend it
Constitution constitutionality which its
own sponsors are on record doubting this
bill is not designed to reduce fraud it
is designed to disenfranchise voters
with no evidence or data to back it up
there is no good reason to erect
barriers that will stop tens of
thousands of Voters from participating
in their
democracy please repeal this bill and if
we need to if we need to amend our our
voter qualifications let's do it
thoughtfully and not the way that this
was handled last year thank you
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um next
up is Kristen
Evans uh on Deck after that will be uh
Sarah
shinard Oh and representative Lane if
you could fill out a pink card for me
thank
you thank you chair and committee
members uh thank you for the opportunity
to testify in support of HB 385 for the
record my name is Kristen Evans and I am
the director of policy for AEL New
Hampshire AEL is a disability Justice
organization and we are nonpartisan
nonprofit organization that fights for
the civil and human rights of children
and adults with disabilities I am here
today because New Hampshire's voter
registration laws are failing people
with disabilities I urge you to support
HB 385 because it is not just a policy
change it is a necessary correction to
an unjust system that has denied far too
many people their fundamental right to
vote right now people with disabilities
are being disenfranchised simply because
they cannot easily obtain the paperwork
the state demands many cannot drive so
they don't have a license others face
insurmountable barriers to access assing
birth certificates or other
documentation barriers make worse by
Financial limitations Mobility
challenges and Bure bureaucratic red
tape under current law these citizens
our neighbors our veterans our seniors
are effectively shut out of the
democratic process that is voter
suppression plain and simple the numbers
prove it according to the US election
assistance commission 11% of Voters
would disabilities reported difficulties
voting in 2020 nearly three times the
rate of non-disabled Voters a Rutter's
University study found that voter
turnout for people with disabilities
lags behind their non-disabled peers by
5.7% points that Gap represents millions
of voices silenced not because they
don't care but because the system is
designed to make it harder for them to
participate HB 385 restores the use of
the qualified a qualified voter
affidavit ensuring that no one is denied
the right to vote simply because they
lack the right paperwork it maintains
election Integrity while making our
democracy more accessible this is not a
partisan issue this is about whether we
believe in a government that truly
represents all of its people New
Hampshire has a choice we can continue
to allow outdated laws to disenfranchise
disabled voters or we can choose
fairness inclusion and democracy I urge
you to vote Yes on HB 38 5 the voices of
the people with disabilities matter
their votes matter and their rights must
be protected thank you thank you will
you be taking questions from the
committee sure are there questions from
the committee representative Wei uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um in the voters who felt disfranchised
with disabilities and whatnot can do you
know what percentage of them were kind
of accessibility issues you know ACC
access to the voting area um
accessibilities in terms of being able
to vote in that capability and then the
identification aspect that you that this
bill pertains to do you know
how those voters that you said were
disenfranchised where that fits in in in
here thank you for the question I don't
have actual numbers on me currently but
I can absolutely get those in that those
uh numbers to you by the end of the day
thank you further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you uh next
up is representative Timothy
Horan thank you very much I'm
representing Timothy Horgan from
straford County district 6 the town of
Durham and um I'm a I don't know if it's
helpful or not but to point this out but
I am one of the co-sponsors of the bills
so I'm very uh glad that representative
Lane stepped forward and did
um a better job of introducing it than I
might have I just want to add well one
key thing is um the list of who's on the
voter list and list of who actually
voted that's a public record so your
name and address and other information
is there so if if there's a large number
of fictitious or improp or people who
don't exist or people who live in
another state or so forth um that's
something that uh can easily be verified
and in fact uh voting when you're not
eligible to vote is a crime um it's
potentially in many cases a felony so
it's uh it's you know it's not something
that not something people would want to
do casually you know it's a high risk
for well voting is important but still
there's a low payout for it so the the
one of the reasons why so few people are
actually caught under this law it's not
because the state isn't looking for them
the Secretary of State's office and the
Attorney General's office actually put a
lot of effort into detecting illegal
voters is because not that many people
take the risk and um as
for and as for out of state voters I
said it's a felony most people live out
of state would rather vote in their own
state election they don't really care
that much about ours so I would I would
so I would say that's one reason why
this bill is unnecessary as well as the
fact that many people well especially
the disabled it's particularly different
many people don't necessarily have all
the necessary documents you know at hand
immediately on on Election Day but they
still want to go go vote and I think
they should be allowed to vote and if
they're doing so illegally um they will
be caught in uh they they'll probably be
caught in due coures subject to fairly
severe penalty so I would say uh and and
guess the flip side of that is there's
always a so-called sufficiently
determined person argument you
especially here in gun bills any
anything that's what guns you always say
well a sufficiently determined person
still um get a gun which is um but the
same thing is true with this officially
determined version could probably use
someone else's identification or forg an
identification so like this doesn't stop
the mythical sufficiently motivated
person it just uh but it does stop have
to ask you to bring your remarks to a
conclusion oh your time inspired I used
up my two minutes yes so I I I would
just say this um this this bill is uh
this bill this is a good bill so I I'm
used I'm so used to testifying against
Bad bills this is a good bill I think it
corrects a mistake that was made last
year and so uh we should we should pass
the bill so there's uh every citizen has
the right to vote will you be taking
questions from the committee sure if
anybody questions from the committee
saying none thank
you um next up is David Trumble from
where
thank you Mr chairman and committee
members my name is David Trumble I'm
from the town of where I support this
this bill sometimes it takes a great
deal of wisdom to acknowledge when an
error has been made and passing
1569 last year was an error the room was
filled with people who came in last year
to testify against that bill telling you
all kinds of circumstances in which
people can't access those documents on
voting day and would lose their right to
vote you heard the stories about people
people whose house were on fire and many
many stories from town clerks all around
the state the statistics were also
offered last time that between one to
4,000 voters in the 2020 and 2022
elections were
disenfranchised because if it would have
been disenfranchised if they could not
have put an affidavit forward as has
been testified in other voting bills New
Hampshire is the 50th most difficult
state to vote in we don't have a voter
fraud problem there was no reason to
take 4,000 people and say we don't want
you to participate in our elections
anymore as for the proof of citizenship
papers the Brennan Center for justice
did a report just last year called
millions of Americans don't have
documents proving their citizenship
readily available almost 22 million
Americans 9% of American citizens don't
have proof of citizenship readily
available and 3.8 million which is more
than 1% don't have these documents at
all because they have been lost
destroyed or stolen there's no way you
can get those documents in time if they
were lost or
destroyed without the the lag time for
you to get a citizenship paper or to get
an out ofst State birth certificate or
file for a pass passport why would we
want to tell thousands of New Hampshire
people you can't vote just because of
circumstances beyond your control it
takes wisdom to admit we were wrong we
all want people to participate in our
democracy no matter what party they're
from thank you perfect uh would you be
taking questions from the committee Mr
Trumble yes sir all right are there
questions seeing none thank you next up
is Matt mushan from 603
forward good morning chairman Barry
members of the committee for the record
my name is Matt musian I live in
Claremont and I is the advocacy and
engagement director for 603 Ford a
nonpartisan nonprofit organization
dedicated to educating activating and
empowering young people in New Hampshire
uh here today to testify in support of
house spill 385 which would Restore New
Hampshire's uh long-standing secure and
accessible voter registration process um
this legislation ensures that every
voter regardless of age background or
life circumstance has a fair and
reasonable opportunity to register and
cast their ballot
um you've heard from other speakers
today so I'll summarize but New
Hampshire has historically set a gold
standard for uh election integrity and
accessibility of our elections for years
voters who lacked documents at the time
of registration could sign a sworn
affidavit under a penalty of perjury
that they uh have their eligibility
verified through existing safeguards
this system worked it was Secure
efficient and upheld folks right to vote
but under the restrictive system in
place today in Hampshire has now one of
the most burdensome voter registration
processes in the
country the impact of these restrictions
uh is real young people and new
residents often do not have immediate
access to documents like birth
certificates or passports making it
harder for them to
register um I would also add that
election officials across our political
Spectrum agree that New Hampshire
elections are safe uh and secure already
um and if this body is serious about
election security we could prioritize
some uh much more proactive reforms um
but today ask you to uh support House
Bill 385 as a common sense solution to
restore proven secure voter registration
process in New
Hampshire and I would take any questions
will you be taking questions um no all
right awesome thank you I think you have
the record for shortest speaker of the
day FY which is a i i consider that to
be the ultimate award but um next up is
uh Sarah shinard and then last up will
be Olivia
zinc hello I'm Sarah shanard I'm with
the New Hampshire campaign for voting
rights and America votes and we are here
in support of HB 385 HB 385 would
restore a critical safeguard for voters
in New Hampshire by repealing hb1 1569 a
law that creat created unnecessary
barriers to voter registration this bill
ensures that eligible voters are not
turned away simply because they lack
immediate access to specific documents
for decades New Hampshire has allowed
voters to register by signing a sworn
affidavit under penalty of perjury if
they did not have proof of identity age
citizenship or domicile that system
worked there was never any evidence of
fraud or
misuse passing hb1 1569 upended that
system forcing voters to provide
specific documents that many do not
carry with them or may struggle to
obtain there are many problems with hb1
1569 but I want to focus on its
requirement for documentary proof of
citizenship it is not difficult to
imagine that many voters do not have a
birth certificate passport or
naturalization papers readily available
acquiring these documents can be a long
and costly process especially for voters
who were born outside of New Hampshire
and cannot acquire a birth certificate
in state or those who have changed their
names and do not have their current name
on a birth certificate HB 385 corrects
this mistake and ensures that all
eligible Granite Staters can exercise
their right to vote I'll take questions
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you last up is Olivia
zinc representative gusowski can you
grab that uh blue sheet for
me uh Miss Z if you want to put the
we're doing testimony written testimony
on the desk now to stop the the
stack thank
you um good morning chairman Barry and
members of the election law for the
record I'm Olivia zinc executive
director of open democracy and I live in
Franklin and I'm testifying in support
of House Bill 385 um this legislation
would reinstate citizens ability to
register to vote um right now you can uh
for identity age citizen ship or
domicile um I'll just say I'm 44 years
old my birth certificate is still in my
baby book at my mom's house she hasn't
given me the document yet so at least I
know where my birth certificate is it's
at my mom's house uh but but some of us
might be estranged from our parents and
not have access to our birth certificate
it's important um that we think about
all voters what about a voter who might
have had a flood or a fire or maybe a
homeless voter that may not have access
to the those documents there are many
reasons why you might not have a p a
passport um such as the cost so I think
it's important that they many these
voters still have the right to vote in
our New Hampshire Constitution um part
two article
11 also this um Bill House Bill 1569
disenfranchises and creates um barriers
to registration um I do have the data uh
from the November 5th
20204 election there were
347 people who didn't have
identification when they were voting
347 um this is in a January 2nd letter
um from the Secretary of State's office
um so I I don't I the vast majority of
Voters at least in my polling place had
to sign an affidavit more than 50% of
Voters had to sign an affidavit
registering to vote for the first time
most of the time it was because they
forgot citizenship paperwork most people
don't show up with nothing they show up
with their driver's license or maybe a
utility bill um but they they there's
four things people have to prove and not
everyone shows up with all of that
paperwork so I think it's important for
us to ensure that every granted Stater
can vote um so please support um this
with an a to
pass one second left you get the award
for closest but not going over it is
prices right rules have five established
um we be taking questions Miss
um are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um on
the blue sheet there were 10 and support
one opposed online it was uh 332 support
72 opposed one neutral um and with that
oops find my gavel uh with that I will
close the public hearing for House Bill
385 FN and open the public hearing for
House Bill 618 enables election
officials to verify the single use of an
out ofate driver's license presented
when a person votes by using the
centralized voter registration database
and I will recognize representative our
own representative C for the purpose of
introduction and representative C you
have not spoken uh to us yet so welcome
to election
law thank you Mr chairman and members of
the election law committee I'm
representative Alvin C of Laden and
representing eight towns in marac
District 26
today I'm here to introduce House Bill
618 uh an act enabling election
officials to verify single use of an
outof state driver's license when
presented when a person votes
using the centralized
uh voter ID
system for this person for this bill we
are assuming a person may have recently
just moved to New Hampshire and not yet
had an opportunity to get their driver's
license exchanged for New Hampshire
driver's license or to get their non-d
driver's
ID this bill would allow such a person
to vote in in their new HomeTown even
when you're using their out of state
driver's license as
identification this person would still
need to confirm their new residents and
show they are indeed voting in the CK
town or
Ward as a single use of their now out of
state identification the supervisor
checklist should point out to this voter
that they will not be permitted to vote
at any subsequent election in New
Hampshire without getting a New
Hampshire's driver's license or ID
card this bill provides a helpful grace
period for a new Resident rather than an
inflexible ban on use of an out ofate
driver's license or ID thank you for
considering this bill and I will take
questions other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um um I
only have one other card signed up to
speak it's Miss Olivia zinc so um
representative you grab the the English
the blue sheet please um that was a
command to myself to speak English and
um with that thank you Miss zinc um I'm
Olivia zinc executive director of open
democracy but I also serve as a city
counselor which makes me a Selectmen in
my polling location and I was asked by
the Peabody home which is the nursing
home in our town to help wheel in
elderly voters at the state primary and
at the state primary I wheeled in an
elderly voter who had a main driver's
license because she's at the nursing
home in Franklin but has a main driver's
license inv voted in the state primary
so if we're if we pass this legislation
we would tell
this voter that they would have to go to
the DMV and get a New Hampshire driver's
license even though they're not d
driving because they're in a wheelchair
and I don't know how they're going to
get down to conquer to get a new
driver's license and they're going to
have to do that between the state
primary and the general election um so I
I think that there are other
circumstances I understand what the
representative is saying is is if a
person is moving into the state they can
they have one time to vote and then they
get a new driver's license that makes
sense for most people who are moving to
the state and and establishing residents
but there are some circumstances like
this resident who voted in my town um in
a nursing home and I don't know that
you're really going to want a
90-year-old to go uh get a new driver's
license probably means that 90-year-old
will not have a constitutional right to
vote happy to take a question are
questions from the committee
representative
wearying so there are uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question Mr Sing uh so uh there are
carve outs Elsewhere
for um elderly voters um you'd be okay
with this as long as there was an
appropriate carve out for the elderly
voters then I I think that that voter is
a is a is one circumstance but I think
you'd want to think about all of the
different people who might like a
military voter for example doesn't isn't
required to get a new driver's license
every place they move so if they're
deployed and and are here for a period
of time
um they could use their a military ID or
their driver's license from another
state so I think there are other
circumstances where people do vote using
out ofate IDs that we we do allow so you
want to think about what are what are
all those circumstances um this was one
story and one example of the elderly
voter at a nursing home but I think you
I think there are military voters and
there might be other voters that have
other circumstances why they they may
use an out of state ID so if you do one
about you should do it for all voters
thank
you represent mhe thank you thanks for
taking my
question my understanding is that the
only function of a photo
ID when a voter prevent present
themselves to the ballot clerk on voting
day is to prove that the person is the
person who they say they are is that
your understanding correct that is my
understanding proving identity so their
name and their photo follow up followup
thank you Mr chair uh thanks for taking
the followup
question given that every state in the
country now uses real ID compliant
driver's licenses is there any reason to
think that a driver's license from any
of the 49 other states of this great
country would prove somebody's identity
in a less reliable way than a New
Hampshire driver's license would prove
their identity no thank you further
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you next up is David Trumble from
where thank you Mr chairman and
committee members my name is David
Trumble from the town ofwar I do oppose
this bill I I certainly understand that
if a person I would say they leave
college and or maybe they go somewhere
else to get a job and they're settling
down in Minnesota or they let were in
Minnesota they came to New Hampshire at
some point they need to establish that
New Hampshire is their home but I I
haven't heard anybody address how this
would affect the college students that
we were talking about earlier because if
you let's say you live in Massachusetts
that's where you grew up you come to UNH
or St a or someplace to go to school
here you have an out of state driver's
license you can use that to identify
yourself one time so let's suppose
you're a very active person you go to
the primary you want to go to your local
elections every single year in March
because you think what's going on at the
local level matters to you you got State
elections every two years during your
four years of college you could easily
vote several times but this this would
say you can't vote in New Hampshire
unless you get a driver's license in New
Hampshire and it that doesn't seem to be
any justifiable reason to put that
restriction on people they are living
here for eight or nine months of the
year this is where they live the laws we
pass affect them very directly they
should be allowed to conduct their civic
life voting in New Hampshire so the
onetime rule doesn't work work for
college students nor would it work
obviously for military people or for
elderly people it's well intentioned to
catch that person who moves in from
Minnesota or Arkansas but there's a
better ways to do that than to take away
people's fundamental right to vote thank
you thank you will be taking questions
yes sir are there questions from the
committee seeing none thank you with
that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 618 um he there
were zero in support here six opposed um
and
online there were 41 in support 220
opposed and three neutral I'm going to
open the notice executive session um for
uh the uh house bills
269 I'm going to recognize uh let me
read the title uh relative to the date
for correction of the voter checklist
I'm going to recognize representative
Wei for a
motion move out to pass is there a
second representative PR Brian seconds
is there a discussion on the motion of
octop pass on House Bill 269 relative to
the date of the correction for the voter
checklist I'll just no is there is there
a discussion just just noting it's a
basically a
housekeeping uh Bill to clear up a
legacy use of the word Saturday um that
was expunged from the RSA in earlier
bills further discussion on the motion
of ought to pass on House Bill
269 are you ready for the question the
clerk will call the
rooll okay representative qua yes
representative Poma Brian yes rep
representative Burnham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes yes representative toner yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative wilham
yes representative Nome yes
representative Howard yes and chairman
Barry chair votes yes with that the
motion ought to pass cares on a vote of
18 to Z is there any objection to this
bill being placed on the consent
calendar hearing none the bill will be
placed on consent toer I will close the
executive session for House Bill 269 I'm
going to announce the recessing of house
bills uh noticed sessions for House Bill
158 relative to the public inspection of
absentee ballot list as well as House
Bill 217 relative to absentee ballots um
we still have two minutes so let's grind
out one more um let's just uh go with
trying to find one that'll be fast
[Music]
um yeah I'm recessing 686 um so yeah I'm
going to announce the recess of 686 um
and I will we'll open up the executive
session for House Bill 608 requiring
moderators to inspect absentee ballot
affidavit for full execution including
the use of a notary election officer or
other person authorized by law to
administer Oaths um I will recognize
represent ative Lane for a
motion I move to itl this bill
representative Lane moves inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 608 is there a
second representative Ward seconds is
there any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate seeing none are you ready for
the
question yes Clark will call the role
thank you for your patience um
representative qua yes representative
fom O'Brien yes representative Burnham
yes representative warry yes
representative wood yes representative
Harvey Bolam yes representative C yes
representative gzowski yes
representative toner yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes yes
representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad representative Bay
yes representative wilham yes
representative Nome yes representative
Howard
yes chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion of inexperience to
legislate carries on a vote of uh 18 to
Zer um it can be placed on the consent
calendar there's objection to the bill
being placed on consent calendar hearing
none the bill will be placed on consent
calendar and spee of legislate
representative Lane who will be
responsible for the report
excuse me point of order yes ma'am I'm
not sure that it can go on consent
because it's a it's inexpedient to
legislate oh okay it's a negative
motion um so uh representative Lane who
will be responsible for the
report me okay and then representative
wey you'll be responsible for the report
on
um 6 269 okay understood um with that I
will see you guys back at 1:00 so I'm
going to uh recess our executive session
I'll see you guys at 1:00 for
hearings
e
e e
good afternoon everybody thank you for
being here in the U momentary absence of
our chairman as Vice chair
I'm going to fill in and open the public
hearing on HB
365 is there someone here to introduce
the
bill uh I don't see the sponsor it is 1
o'clock so I'm going to ask that uh
representative
toner uh come to the microphone and just
give a brief introduction of the bill
and we'll proceed
hello I'm representative Travis toner
from
Belmont um I'd like to introduce House
Bill 365 FN um relative to or this bill
provides for a procedural for local
election officials and the Secretary of
State to verify the citizenship of the
voter who does not have documentary
proof of citizenship this bill also
creates a voucher program for local
election officials to give Indigent
voters who cannot afford cost of
obtaining uh birth birth certificate
requires the Secretary of State to
reimburse the municipality for issuance
of such vouchers and makes an
appropriation thereof and I will not be
taking questions I hope I did it right
okay thank you very
much uh well next we'll move on to
Witnesses and I will ask uh Secretary of
State David scanland to share his
thoughts with us thank you very much Mr
secretary thank you Mr chairman uh
members of the committee I'm David
scanland Secretary of State and I'm here
to generally support this bill um there
is no question that in the last session
of the
legislature the um requirements for
registering to vote uh tightened up
quite a bit where uh prospective voters
are now required to provide documents
that show
qualifications uh in including
qualifications for
citizenship that is also an issue that
has taken on some significance
nationally where many states are
concerned uh with the citizenship
verification
issue and there has been uh greater
demands placed on the federal government
agencies who have databases that that
house citizenship information to make
that information available to the state
so that they can do a better job
verifying
checklists this bill is specific to
individuals that are uh Indigent that
may have trouble finding uh their
citizenship
documentation uh frankly I think the
issue is broader than that that there
may be individuals that might need help
who are not Indigent and I think that
should be a consideration when you're
discussing this bill um at the secretary
of state level uh I've been working with
other
secretaries uh trying to get the federal
agencies to be a little bit more
proactive and helpful in terms of making
the information and their citizenship
databases more readily available for
this purpose and hopefully we will make
some success
there um in terms of the the fiscal note
and the requirement that the Secretary
of State reimburse municipalities for
vouchers that are issued to obtain birth
certificate
information um I think that's a positive
thing I will say that the division of
Vital Records is within the Secretary of
State's office
and those documents are issued from
vital records and we actually build the
towns when they issue birth certificates
and things like that so um we may be
able to just give a waiver or something
instead of having a you know policy of
reimbursement so U with all of that said
I'm happy to answer any questions other
questions from the
committee representative wood I don't
know if um this came up your discussion
oh first of all thank you taking my
question um what is the cost for this
roughly um I noticed we talk about
Indigent and there's no definition I'm
assuming that they just have to claim to
be Indigent answer could you answer that
question how do you claim how how do you
make this claim how do you define it
thank you we have a great example um
right now with voter ID if a voter who
does not have a driver's license or a
non-driver ID issued by
DMV uh can can they can a person who is
Indigent can go to the
clerk and assert that they do not have
either of those two uh uh IDs and the
clerk will issue a voucher for that
voter to go to DMV and obtain a an ID
for voting purposes
only and in that case the secretary of
state will reimburse the Division of
Motor Vehicles for the production of
that ID it is used very very very
infrequently most people have the ID
that they need for that purpose this may
be a little bit different and you know I
don't know how many people might uh want
to ex exercise the voucher
process but to the extent that that
other individuals may also need this
help that the Secretary of State's
office may require some resources to
help cover the costs of paying for the
searches that are done at the federal
level um and designating someone to uh
go through that
process we want people to to go through
the exercise of showing that you know
they're qualified to be a voter we don't
want that process to be
honorous um and to the extent that we
can be helpful I think we should be
follow yes thank you for the followup
thank you for answering the question
better than I posed it um what do you
what do you estimate the cost for one
person to get this information do you
have a rough
idea uh not not a good idea but what I
can tell you is that that there are
federal agencies now that will look up
citizenship
information upon request but there's a a
fee that goes along with that I think
it's might be between $3 and $4 for each
search that they
do other questions from the
committee representative Lane thank you
and thank you for taking my question um
do other states have a similar
requirement to
this other states require um that voters
provide
documentation more and more states are
including citizens ship in that
um I know that uh the law that passed in
New Hampshire is maybe stricter than
most um but I know that there are many
states that are dealing with this
issue I have followup please yes thank
you um last session a similar bill was
brought in for Roman
numeral two which is lines three through
and it became apparent that the types of
U databases and the sharing of that
information was not um up and running so
to speak and it sounded like we were
saying that it's still not up and
running is that did I misunderstand or
is that the case no that is the case
there is no single database that a
person can go to and get citizenship
information from uh citizens of the
United States there are three or four
federal agencies that have citizenship
information uh they have different
requirements to be able
to get that information from them and so
there really does need to be a
coordinated effort if uh documentation
is going to be required at the state
level to prove
citizenship to have the feds help make
that information more readily available
and that is an ongoing uh
process further questions from the
committee representative promo Brian
thank you
sir uh I want to follow up on a question
that was just asked uh about the cost of
getting non non um non-driver
identification
so if a person is this is bothering me
my face um
if a person is is unable to afford
getting um an
ID they just simply would make that
known to the clerk and then the clerk
would tell you and then you wouldn't be
charging them for it so there's not an
honorous procedure for this person to go
through to prove that they don't have
the funding for to pay for that that's
is that how it is
so right now with with proving identity
for obtaining
a uh a ballot at the polling
place an Indigent person who does not
have any form of photo ID doesn't have a
driver's license or a non-driver ID can
go to the clerk and say I can't
afford this you know getting this ID
card I do not have a driver's license I
do not have um a non-driver
ID and they assert that to the clerk the
clerk can then issue a voucher that that
individual can take with them to any
motor vehicle office and have that ID
produced for them for no charge but then
the Secretary of State uh honoring that
voucher will be assessed by the DMV I
think it's $10 or so for each ID that's
issued representative Bay thank you Mr
chair uh um thank you for taking my
question um without the definition of a
clear definition of indigent as a
representative would
indicated so
if uh if this is for proving citizenship
so the and they can't afford to get the
documentation to prove citizenship
wouldn't
that by implication
Define the Indigent to be whatever is
the most expensive uh rout
to get proof of citizenship so if you
can't afford that then you're
Indigent I that's a good question and I
think it's a debatable uh definition um
one thing I should say is that this
voucher system that is in this bill
would only work
for citizens who were born in New
Hampshire um I don't think the state of
Pennsylvania is going to honor a voucher
from a New Hampshire town clerk so
um so that's important and and that's
why I suggested at the very beginning
that this issue is broader than just
defining indigency there are going to be
individuals no matter what that may have
trouble coming up with documents that
they may have lost got burned up in a
fire or you know a wide variety of
things that I think we're going to have
to be willing to to help those
individuals
with further questions from the
committee representative
Lane thank you and thank you again for
taking my question um is this more of a
a policy decision for the legislature to
make is this a policy decision yes thank
you further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much Mr
secretary a pleasure as
always calling the next witness uh Iris
Iris
eltio
iris2 oh you know what I had the wrong
you're right thank you very much I don't
have to do
another one for
472 okay uh back on track that next
witness McKenzie
Taylor Miss
Taylor good afternoon members of the
committee um McKenzie Taylor with New
Hampshire campaign for voting rights and
America votes and we are uh testifying
in opposition to house Bill 365 um this
bill attempts to create a system that
would assist voters in providing
citizenship however as we've think
already heard there this is not a system
that is going to be foolproof and the
best way to ensure that no voter is
turned away for lack of citizenship
documents specifically is to bring back
the affidavit process and let voters
attest their citizenship by sworting a
sworn Aid or signing a sworn affidavit
um as far as I understand no other state
um requires physical documentary proof
of citizenship when registering there
are other states that once folks are
registered they might look backwards and
and try to confirm that citizenship but
New Hampshire is the only state where uh
when you are registering you need to
have that document or be turned away um
I know also that I think it's upwards of
80% of Voters in New Hampshire probably
changes a little bit via which election
register in person at the polls on
Election Day where even in the bill it
says it's not likely that we are able to
take the time to find the citizenship
proof for most of those voters big
concern about having required
documentary proof of citizenship is
folks having to get to the polls with
that passport or birth certificate with
them and then be it takes an hour two
hours days to find their citizenship in
those federal or state databases that is
not going to happen on election day and
those folks are therefore going to be
turned away um this doesn't solve the
issue of people not realizing that their
real ID does not solve proof of show
proof of citizenship um and then as
you've heard you know this is the
Secretary of State say this is really
only for voters the the birth
certificate process for voters who were
born in New Hampshire um according to
nhpr an article in 2019 about a third of
New Hampshire voters were born in the
state um so those folks have their birth
certificates in state databases but the
other 23s will need to go out of state
often this is not just an issue of cost
but of time weeks or months or systems
to try to get those birth certificates
um that again are not going to be able
to be found on Election Day or in the
days leading up to election day uh and
finally when we're thinking about birth
certificates wanted to note that uh they
don't have correct names for every voter
I'm one person who is changing their
name currently uh 79% of women when they
get married change their last name and
for those voters they cannot use birth
certificates to show uh their full name
and proof of citizenship and I'm happy
to take questions okay thank you uh will
you take questions sure do we have any
questions from the
committee representative
Lane um thank you and thank you for
taking my question um I think you
mentioned this in previous testimony on
a different bill but one of the reasons
my understanding was one of the reasons
that we don't have a lot of problems
with
non-citizens trying to get
away and and fraud
defrauding uh registration is because
there's severe penalties if they do that
could you explain what those might be
yes my understanding when you sign an
affidavit generally there you're
assigning that under um penalty of
perjury um it's also illegal to vote if
you are not a citizen in New Hampshire
so if you were to vote as not a citizen
um I'm not an attorney but I believe
that you could be facing penalties
including deportation for doing that
since it's against the
law
for representative Gilmore thank you um
am I correct in assuming that this is
part of the HB 1569 that just went into
effect after the election that change
the change of needing documentary proof
of citizenship was created with that
bill yeah thank
you further questions from the
committee uh representative Harvey
Buller thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um I just wanted
to quickly uh go back to what you're
were saying about the other states I
didn't know if you were aware that there
are about 26 other states um that
require photo ID is that what you were
saying not photo thank you for the
question um I talking about proof of
citizenship which is what we're talking
about in this bill in terms of you know
a photo ID lots of states need you need
in New Hampshire but a birth certificate
naturalization papers or passport
especially when registering to vote as a
proactive like documentary proof um as
far as I understand at this point Point
only New Hampshire has that requirement
other states might look it up afterwards
to prove it but um we're the only state
where when you go in and register in
person now if you don't have that
document for citizenship with you um
you're going to be turned
away and I to add a real ID um does not
prove citizenship as well that is a
thing to note further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much
next up misss Olivia
zinc good afternoon um for the record my
name is Olivia zenc a voter in Franklin
and executive director of um open
democracy I wish I I wish there was an
option to say I wish we could do better
uh so I do think that this is a good
first step in you know making it a
available for people uh to be able to
vote but if you're going to take an
affidavit that says I swear I'm
poor why don't you just take the
affidavit that says I swear I'm a
citizen right that it just makes me
think oh people should just swear on an
affidavit that says I'm a citizen we
accept that proof and not make them sign
an affid David that says I'm poor so
that they can get a voucher to get a get
their birth certificate
um we also have people that are adopted
who may not be have the same name as
their birth certificate so then do they
need the adoption certificate married
women who Chang their names will they
require marriage certificates will the
state help get marriage certificates or
only the birth certificate but if the
birth certificate doesn't have the same
name because their marriage certificate
changed now now that voter still is
disenfranchised so I think uh your
better bet is to just allow them
an affidavit to swear citizenship and
not have an affidavit that swears their
poor also what what what does this
there's no definition of this so can can
anyone say they're poor and sign a piece
of
paper I think that that we there's no
clarification on that um also we're only
allocating $25,000 for birth certificate
vouchers from the Secretary of State
what happens to the person who might be
that sort of the person that goes over
that threshold if that dollar amount has
already spent will we allocate a few
more dollars if if needed or or do we
just cut that off at
$25,000 um for those reasons I urge the
committee to vote
itl thank you uh questions from the
committee seeing none thank you very
much I have uh one more pink card here
there is representing able New Hampshire
but there's no name on
it Sarah
Shard so would you would you please
state your name so I can I'll write it
in for
you BL BLC she please thank you uh for
the record my name is Kristen Evans and
I'm the director of policy for Abel New
Hampshire I have submitted written
testimony I think everything that uh
Abel we were going to say has been said
so I will just say that um we are
against this bill and hope that you
would vote um
itl well thank you welcome would you
take questions any questions from the
committee I I have
one representative Lane thank you um do
you have written ter testimony yes could
you submit it please I did thank you
you're welcome okay thank you uh further
questions seeing none thank you very
much
okay
um didn't participate in that one
because I was in and out of the room and
I'm on the bill and I was just like it's
best just to let the uh the VC Captain
the ship for a minute um so on the blue
sheet for 365 we had one in favor nine
opposed um signed up who did not speak
and then online 365
was uh 48 support 421 oppose one neutral
with that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 365 FN and open
the public hearing on House Bill 472
requiring voters to prove
domicile and pull my bill up
here sure
um I'll allow it yes since did you when
you did you fill out a pink
card oh so the blue sheet okay very
common mistake it's okay uh blue sheet
is you're signed up you're not signing
up to speak You're Just signing in your
position so go ahead uh we I'll I'll
without objection I will allow the
member of the public to give his
testimony on
365 um and after you're done um fill out
a pink card for us
okay no worries not a big deal it's uh I
think it'll be wrong to not let you
speak
so yeah hold on a second I got to reopen
it I'm going to I'm going to recess 4
472 I'm going to reopen 365 and
recognize the member of the public to
speak uh thank you Mr chair my name is
Phil Hatcher I'm from Dober it's very
nice to see two of my own reps on this
committee today um I've worked in
various roles in do W 3 polling place
since 2019 um uh right currently I am
the award 3 award clerk um during those
five or six years I've worked with two
City Clerks uh who have repeatly told me
they don't see evidence of voting fraud
in our city um this agrees with what
I've been told by other election
officials around the state and also
agrees with the final report of the
Secretary of State's special committee
on voter confidence but for that reason
I was opposed to HP
1569 when it was under discussion last
spring and was disappointed to see it
passed into
law um it seemed to me that that was a
kind of
extreme uh solution to a problem that
doesn't exist um and one that will
likely disenfranchise some voters this
seems even more true
today with all uh due respect to the
Secretary of State I don't see a you
know a concentrated public
announcement of this major change in
election law being propagated out to the
public so I'm worried about people
showing up next month to vote in their M
elections and being surprised that this
is in
effect um so in fact I want to thank the
sponsors of HP 365 for apparently
recognizing that there are flaws in the
bill that was passed last year and now
seeking
remediation um and it's it's encouraging
that they're so prominent
themselves the two chairs of the
election law committees plus the
original sponsor of the bill um but I
don't think HB 365 is an effective
remedy uh echoing some of what people
have said before um but in particular it
won't help voters who are registering on
Election Day at least it doesn't
guarantee much
help um which perhaps reflects that New
Hampshire no longer is going to have an
effective election day registration
system as required by federal law since
the state took a pass on Motor Voter way
back when
um in addition as secretary himself
alluded um the ability of this secretary
state's office to help voters prove in
particular their citizenship is is
dubious at this point in
time um in a February 9th article in the
Washington Post the Republican
secretaries of state of Iowa and Ohio
are quoted complaining about the
difficulty in getting accurate
citizenship data from the federal
government sir I'm not to ask you to
bring your marks to conclusion that your
time has expired these complaints have
been echoed in recent years by many
Democrats complaining about e
verify so if hb65 has passed I'm afraid
we're going to have three divisions of
Voters those who have already access to
their documents those who don't but this
Secretary of State can help and everyone
else is out of luck um and in fact this
differentiation between voters is why we
have a citizenship affidavit in the
first place if you go back and look at
the law and I I'll refer you since my
time is expiring to representative
Gilmore who despite his youthful
appearance actually served on the
election law committee when a citizen
affidavit was put into effect again
thank you for allowing me to testify
today I'll submit my full written
testimony thank you no worries um qu we
taking questions from the committee sure
are the questions from the committee
seeing none thank thank you going to
reclose the public testimony on House
Bill 365 going to open the public
hearing on House Bill 472 and recognize
representative Penza for the purpose of
introduction
oops sorry thank you Mr chair uh for the
record representative Kelly Penza
straford District 19 I have another
hearing that I have to be at uh that
goes at 1:30 so uh this is a very simple
bill um that basically it's the same
thing uh similar to what was put forward
in regards with um an IDE identification
bill um voters have need need two pieces
and um of course we need to know we have
to verify their identity and we also
have to verify that they actually um are
do ailed here in New Hampshire so um
basically um when I moved from one
section of Rochester to another I had to
prove that I did and I brought in my my
lease for um where we live and every
voter should be have to do that so it's
it's pretty simple um and of course uh
from a friend of mine that is a
supervisor of the checklist this past uh
election it was um quite crazy and there
was things that were rushed through
where um where there wasn't you know
necess neily a proof of residency of
domicile because it was you know there
were long lines and all of that so this
puts it into statute and makes it
crystal clear that in addition to
approving your identity you also have to
prove that you reside here in domiciled
in New
Hampshire to
vote will you be taking questions from
the committee can I not yeah absolutely
you cannot in fact that's my preference
um so all right easy enough thank you um
next up is Secretary of State David
scanland
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David scanland Secretary
of State and I just wanted to raise some
concerns that I had with this piece of
legislation and I've shared these
concerns with representative Penza so
she's she is aware of them um the
check-in process for a voter now
requires that a voter show their
acceptable form of
ID and once that's done the ballot
clerks will then ask the voter if their
address is still XYZ Main
Street uh if it is not the voter simply
gives the new address to the ballot
clerk who then writes the the new
address in red ink on the uh on the on
the
checklist the reason for that is so the
supervisors can just keep their lists up
to date they'll take that information
and they'll correct the checklist at a
later time there is no requirement in
the statute that a voter has to prove
their domicile at the same time they're
checking in just to get a ballot that
process takes place when the voter
registers with the supervisors of the
checklist and now under state law that
docum that documentation has to be
provided when that event happens and so
what is happening here is kind of
conflation of the different uh processes
that take place and if the process in
House Bill
472 were to pass it would be somewhat
chaotic uh when people are checking in
uh not having the document that they
need having to go over to the
supervisors of the checklist for some
type of a verification it's just going
to cause lines to back up and on a day
like we had last
November uh it could be a disaster so
that's the concern I have is that we
have distinct processes that take place
they both work really well and we should
not do anything that is going to cause
confusion in that process so with that
I'd be happy to answer any
questions other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um next
up trying to do members of the public
here think I only have one member of the
public uh suasi from
Rollinsford hello yeah I'm suasi from
Rollinsford and I wanted to say that
when a voter registered
the domicile is verified at that point
as secretary scandin said it's
verified and by the town or city clerk
or
supervisor and all information per voter
is saved online which is available to
the ballot clerk on Election Day and
checked with um the ID when uh the voter
wants to get a ballot and um uh what I
see is that there isn't any need for
this bill when I verified um my own
doile it was like a day after our house
closing and I brought in our uh closing
papers right to the town clerk and it
stayed right there and um it's been the
same and so far as uh having to
verify um domicile
um
again um uh I I don't see the need
because it's online and plus uh checking
that when the voter comes on Election
Day thank you okay and will you be
taking questions from the committee are
there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you uh next up is
Kristen Evans with Abel New
Hampshire uh on Deck is Iris
uh Al to Leo thank
you thank you chair and committee
members uh thank you for the opportunity
to testify in opposition of HB 472 for
the record my name is Kristen Evans and
I am the director of policy for AEL New
Hampshire and AEL is a disability
Justice organization and we are
nonpartisan nonprofit organization that
fights for the civil and human rights of
children and adults with disabilities I
am here today to express our strong
opposition to
hp472 a bill that represents a troubling
Trend in this legislative session a
deliberate effort to chip away at the
voting rights of marginalized
communities particularly those
individuals with disabilities this
session alone we have witnessed an
alarming number of bills designed to
impose additional barriers to voting
hp472 is a prime example introducing
onerous requirements for proving
domicile that disproportionately affect
voters with disabilities low-income
individuals and those in non-traditional
housing situations many disabled voters
reside with family members or in
assisted living facilities and do not
possess documents like utility bills or
leases in their names this bill fails to
consider their realities effectively
disenfranchising eligible voters the
current system already mandates that
voters provide domicile
hp472 seeks to complicate this process
further granting election officials
undue discretion to reject voters based
on arbitrary standards if a voter's
residency is challenged their only
recourse is to appeal immediately to the
Superior Court a daunting and often
unfeasible option for individuals with
Mobility challenges cognitive
disabilities or limited access to Legal
resources the sheer number of
restrictive voting bills introduce the
session is not only disheartening but
it's also infuriating it reflects a
persistent attempt to erode the
accessibility and inclusivity of our de
Democratic process instead of erecting
barriers we should be enacting policies
that facilitate participation for all
eligible voters ensuring that everyone
can exercise their fundamental right to
vote with dignity and ease hp472 is an
affront to the principle of fairness and
equality it does nothing to enhance
election security but serves only to
disenfranchise those who already face
significant obstacles I urge this
committee to reject this harmful
legislation and affirm your commitment
to protecting the voting rights of all
Granite St Staters especially to those
who are the most vulnerable thank you
thank you nobody taking questions yes
are there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you next up
is
Iris I was GNA get there sorry no I
wasn't I I was I was going to look I was
going to stare at it and and hope I'm
used to it before I was married it was
worse so thank you committee for taking
for hearing my testimony today my name
is Iris altilio I am from Penbrook New
Hampshire I'm speaking as a citizen as a
senior citizen and a representative of
ARP so I'm wearing my red I'm also
speaking as a supervisor of the
checklist and I recently retired from
the conquered coalition to end
homelessness so I understand the
problems of the homeless as well um also
I do appreciate what you do because I
was the committee assistant for this
committee prior to to covid so I'm very
familiar with your job um I'm speaking
against this bill and I'm speaking
against this bill because first of all
it's confusing I don't remember the name
of the sponsor because I'm old but she
did say that this bill was related to a
person and it almost sounded like
registering not voting and then the
Secretary of State who I can who I agree
with said seemed to say that this bill
requires everybody to provide proof of
doic when they walk up to the ballot
clerk but when I looked at the bill it
sounded like only people who don't have
ID have to provide proof of Dell so
right away I don't know what this bill
is doing so it's hard to speak to it
however as everybody said it is very
difficult now for people to register to
vote if they don't have their ID um at
this point it's going to disenfranchise
disenfranchise some voters um and then
again I'm going to ask what's the
probability how many of you walk around
with your deed or your lease in your
hand probably not most of you so it's
not that practical either so as a
supervisor of the checklist my job is to
maintain accurate voting records to
maintain the Integrity of the elections
and to encourage voting this is not
going to encourage voting and it's
probably not going to really do the best
job of maintaining the Integrity of the
elections either and that's because the
way I read this if you don't have ID you
can go you can uce your proof of
domicile and you're allowed to vote so
you're voting without ID now I could be
totally wrong so please read the bill
and you know check it out and see what
you say by the way I do have testimony I
put some more information in my
testimony I didn't want to speak that
long so it's not in here excellent thank
you um I do want to say a couple more
things well your time has expired ma'am
so I need you to oh it's more than three
minutes okay it's two minutes oh I'm
sorry I didn't realize I had two minutes
okay so then I just want to wrap up
really quickly and um say I really do
hope that you look at this bill see that
it's it is confusing and please um do
not vote for it thank you thank you will
you be taking questions I will are there
questions from the committee okay oh
representative
Mirad is there anything really important
that you wanted to say that you didn't
have time to say uh is
there um probably not I am giving you my
written testimony probably not thank you
question where do I put it uh so put it
on the desk please okay yeah that way
members can come by at the end and pick
everything up at once and not have
the not have the show um I was going to
ask what would you have done if you were
committee assistant you had 75 bills
so um next up is Kaylee uh
estadio oh yeah we have more
um thank you chairman Barry and members
of the committee my name is kayy of
stadio I'm a Durham voter and public
policy fellow with open democracy and
I'm testifying today in opposition to
this bill um I feel it places an
unnecessary burden on both voters who
have already shown proof of their
domicile at the time they registered as
well as on checklist supervisors who as
we all know are already swamped on
Election Day seeing that this
requirement is not currently employed by
any other state in the country the
reality is that the effects of HB 472
would largely go unnoticed by the
majority of granite Staters until it is
way too late I Envision this leading to
mass confusion and congestion on already
busy election days as voters who show up
with the wellestablished photo ID
requirement but no proof of domicile at
the ready line up for the supervisor of
the checklist to individually review
each of their qualifications and
identity RSA 65913 currently requires
voters to provide a valid form of photo
ID ensuring an accurate and efficient
voter check system needlessly
double-checking proof of Voters domicile
when it has already been established
will only work to lengthen the tiring
weight in line on election days spur
controversy between ballot clerks and
voters and create yet another hurdle
Grant Staters must jump in order to
enact their constitutional right to vote
so for these reasons I urge you to vote
hb42 and expedient to legislate I also
have a little bit of testimony on behalf
of Susan Moore she is a supervisor of
the checklist from Franconia she urges
you as well to oppose this bill um she
says without question this is a voter
suppression bill every voter on the
voter list has had to prove domicile in
order to register to vote the new
requirement presented in this bill would
mean that voters who do not have their
current address on their ID would need
additional documents to receive the
ballots the voters will be sent to the
supervisors of the checklist and these
voters would need to have proof of
residency domicile consisting of a
utility bill lease deed or similar
documentation of the voter's domicile
address it is highly unlikely residents
who have voted in Prior elections would
have these documents with them and we
would have to turn them away as a
supervisor of the checklist I can
foresee big problems if this becomes the
new law I would also note that the
reference to an appeal to the Superior
Court does not appear to site the
correct RSA please oppose this Bill
thank you thank you will you be taking
questions from the committee yes thank
you seeing none thank you uh
representative sellers are is your
committee meeting is your committee
currently meeting okay would you mind if
I finish the two people in front of you
and then we'll let you introduce thank
you um next up is McKenzie Taylor and
then on Deck is Henry Clement totz uh
and after that I have no more pink cards
for this bill so representative gasowski
can you grab me the um blue sheet
please thank you members of the
committee McKenzie Taylor with America
votes and the New Hampshire campaign for
voting rights um a lot has been already
said in opposition to this bill so I
will be very brief um reminding folks
that again folks are show their domicile
uh andove that with documents when they
register to vote and then are just
showing their identity when they are
checking in to vote um I'm one of the
many New Hampshire voters probably who
at some point did not have their current
address on their license um when I moved
in 2019 from my apartment to my current
house I updated my address with the DMV
but did not get a new license and from
2019 until 20124 I think the
presidential primary I voted and checked
in with that license that had an old
address on it which was compliant I
confirmed my updated address and went on
my way um if I had if this Bill had been
in effect I would have had to bring a
separate document my car registration I
normally walk to the polls it live very
close by um and I think that is a story
that could be uh affected by or happened
to many many voters if this bill was
passed um and is unnecessary and only is
going to um result in longer lines for
people when they're checking in
confusion and uh folks potentially being
turned away so and I'm happy to to take
any questions questions from the
committee I'm saying none thank you last
up is Henry clemento from the
ACLU good afternoon my name is Henry
clemento I'm the deputy legal director
of the ACLU of New Hampshire and I will
be even briefer than Miss
Taylor uh I agree with everything the
Secretary of State said about this bill
and I I think that's a first for me so
I'm happy to take any questions
you're moving me towards supporting the
bill this this is how you get my support
um any questions from the committee all
right seeing sorry we do oppose the bill
I know yeah yeah okay sorry that's what
I meant you're moving to me to support
your position excuse me I I misspoke
um uh any other any other members of the
public wish to speak to house bill um
472 seeing none uh I'm going uh the blue
sheet was 1 to 12 one Pro 12 against
online was 52 in support 388 opposed and
two neutral that I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 472 I'm
going to open the public hearing on
House Bill 172 restricting Undeclared
voters from voting in presidential or
state primaries and I'm going to
recognize representative sellers for the
purpose of introduction representative
sellers welcome to election
law thank you Mr chair thank you
committee members for giving me a few
minutes uh to introduce this bill on
representative cellers from Grafton 10
which represents Bristol Bridgewater in
Hampshire this bill uh HB 172 of course
I support it and it's a very simple
change and it uh as you can see it's
about three lines so I don't think I
need to read it but what I want to point
out is a few things and and one of the
things is uh you you all had I believe
you all get a letter from uh
a Robert
B bille in any case he he actually says
the same thing thing I would be saying
so I'm not going to say it twice and he
probably says it better than I do and I
just want to point out a few items here
all right he says um House Bill 172 will
correct the confusion in IG
IG that uh currently exist in our State
statue all right and uh what the prim it
goes on to say regarding the uh
participation and non-member of
political party election in should be
partially closed primary system and then
he goes and quotes our
RSA um 659 col
141 and I'm just going to read the very
last part of that it says the the
primary shell also announce the name of
the party at the time of announcing the
person's name and basically we're saying
here the person has to be in the party
all right has to be in the party in
order to you order to be in the primary
to vote in that party's
election and it goes on to say three
things the bill does it eliminates
eliminates the same day registration by
Undeclared it requires Undeclared to
register with the Party by the same
deadline as regular party members and it
continues to allow new and firsttime
voters to register uh to vote in the
primary so that part doesn't change so
if it new or first time time you can
still register on the primary
day um another thing I'll point out
here is a basic uh function of the
political party is to um elect select
the candidate for the public office to
be offered to the voters at the general
election into the prime Obed to of most
voters in associate themselves with the
primary party must securely be to gain a
voice in The Selection process so the
idea our primary is to select one or
even two people if they're if you're
being Primary in the primary to that
point is coming from that party and that
that it doesn't matter if it's
Republican or Democrat you should be
allowed to select who you want and what
happens is the and and I've seen it
happen and I know it happens is on
primary day um maybe the other party has
a strong candidate so the person in that
party will actually literally go and
register for the other party and they're
Undeclared so they normally might vote
one way but they decided on this primary
to vote another way and it actually um
skews who actually
gets elected to go forward for the prime
uh for the
general
um one other thing is this writer said
he said many opponents of the bill say
that this violates their constitutional
rights and will dis franchise
Undeclared uh voters from voting in the
primaries again he he mentions here the
Supreme Court says otherwise it's a b
election versus Lopez Torres 552 us 196
commer 202-
03 uh parentheses 2008 the courot said a
political party has the First Amendment
right to limmit the membership as it
wishes and to choose a candidate select
process that will in its uh view produce
the nominee that best represents the
political
platform so along with
that this would be no different than the
Red Sox playing the
Yankees and the Red Sox telling the
Yankees hey by the way you're going to
use this picture today against us so and
you wouldn't want that so I'm going to
leave it there just give you an idea and
there is another bill hb2 20 that you're
going to be hearing and that bill there
will actually allow the party to make
the rules just thought they're in
place I I'll try to answer any questions
the best I can okay other questions from
the
committee see n thank you uh next up is
aen
Osborne uh hello thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee my name is
aan Osborne I'm a resident of Auburn and
just a few days ago I reached the legal
voting age as soon as my schedule
permits I intend to register to vote as
an independent voter I oppose this bill
precisely because it prevents exactly
what I intend to do when participating
in primary elections the ability to swap
my party affiliation at will gives me
the option to vote in whichever primary
contains the candidates who support the
same views and principles as me please
don't take this option away from
independent voters please vote itl on HB
172 and I'll take questions if people
have them all right are there questions
from the committee you stole my thunder
I was going to wish you happy birthday
but you already said so thank you so
much next up is Sue Nasi from
Rollinsford um on Deck is Liz tanter
hello okay suasi from Rollinsford and
this bill restricting Undeclared voters
from same day voting in a presidential
or state primary this bill purposely
cuts out about 40% of the state's
voters in the bill description of change
of registration or same day
registration um that can't be acceptable
when those
um Undeclared or independent they
they're registered as
Undeclared and um register without a
party
affiliation and I also look at it as be
free to
vote as the voter
wishes and that is so important
especially in this
state and um so I I really oppose this
bill and should not go past the
committee thank you will you be taking
questions from the committee yes are
there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you next up is Liz
tantarelli on Deck is Tiana Tiani
Coleman hi Liz tentarelli from
Manchester I'm testifying simply on
behalf of
myself um and I have been an Undeclared
voter here in New Hampshire for 25 years
and I want to continue that I look at
the candidates who are running and I
decide that that time when I'm going
which party I'm going to vote for if
this bill passes I would have to choose
the party before I even know who the
candidates are and I have voted for
State Rep state senator executive
counselors depending on who the
candidates are their
qualifications and how closely they
match my values
not by their party I'm not the only
person who does this we've got 40% of
the voters as Sue mentioned in New
Hampshire who are Undeclared and I
believe that if we want to retain the
Integrity of the first in the nation
primary where voters are really looking
at the candidates not party affiliation
when they vote then you're going to have
to itel this bill and I'm not taking
questions on that thank
you okay next up is Tiani Coleman on
Deck is Olivia
zinc hello this is Tiani Coleman and I
am a resident of Amherst New Hampshire
and today I'm here as myself a citizen
who is an independent voter as well as
president of New Hampshire independent
voters uh first off as has been said
there are approximately 40% of
independent voters here in New Hampshire
which is a greater percentage than
either the Democrat or the Republican
parties have so we are a a large number
of Voters and we should not be told that
we need to belong to a party in order to
participate in a consequential election
and since there are so many elections
here in New Hampshire where there are no
third party choices there are no
independent candidates that means that a
lot of big decisions will be made in
primaries and if we're left out of the
primaries then it is actually not fair
to us it's not equal protection under
the law um we should not have to decide
we should not have to decide and
although the title of the bill is you
know talking about same day registration
I hope that you won't let that fool you
because what this bill is actually doing
is closing the primary it's the same
thing as the other bill you have that's
closing the primary because if you do
not let independent voters register at
the party on the day of registration
then that's the same as telling them
they have to register with the party way
in
advance uh also I don't know if it's
been mentioned but it's actually
unconstitutional this bill for a
different reason it's unconstitutional
because the Supreme Court at least up
until now has said that parties do have
the right of
Association and what that means is that
the state cannot tell the parties who
can and cannot vote in their primaries
so if a party wants to allow independent
voters to vote in their primaries the
state can't tell them that that those
independent voters cannot vote in their
primaries so you need to allow the
parties to make that decision rather
than the state imposing that decision
upon the parties I think that is just
about all other than that I have
conducted a lot of surveys for of
independent voters here in New Hampshire
that are part of Nationwide surve
surveys and independent voters people
who are Undeclared voters for most of
them the large large majority it's it's
a decision that they make consciously
it's not just because they didn't bother
to register with the party they really
do not want to belong to a party for
reasons have been mentioned already for
example they vote for the person not the
party also they might vote for issues in
a very nuanced way and so they determine
it based on a very careful examination
of what the candidates stand for what
they're saying what's going on in in
their area at that time and they do not
vote based on party and they don't want
to be told that they have to join a
party to participate in a consequential
election which is publicly funded by the
way thank you very
much okay takeing no questions so next
up is Olivia
zinc and then on Deck will
be uh they didn't write their first name
I can't read it l Bing bigs
Bings
Briggs what's the first name Linda Lynn
l y l y n
in good afternoon um my name is Olivia
zinc executive director of open
democracy and I'm a voter in Frank
Franklin and I oppose House Bill 1 um 72
I'm a bit going to be a bit of a data
nerd here instead of telling you a story
but the Undeclared party uh as of the
state Primary in September uh three 30
324,000 Undeclared voters that's bigger
than the Republican party or the
Democratic party and names on check
checklist largest party we have um over
6,000 people registered to vote on the
same day as the September primary so the
people who are registering same day
um will have to declare a party because
they won't be able to register
Undeclared but a lot of Voters who
register on same day do register
Undeclared I did cite in the September
primary that there is 41,000 voters that
were Undeclared that C Cast Democratic
ballot and 36,000 Undeclared voters that
uh voted Republican I have the breakdown
by County um but I think that almost
72,000 voters would not be able to vote
if this bill came law because they're
Undeclared voters that voted in the
state primary um I have a story from
Linda who is a ballot clerk in antrum um
she believes that this would
disadvantage Undeclared voters but as a
ballot clerk about a third of the voters
that came in are Undeclared and picked a
party on the same day um she believes
that many of them will not know that
this new rule exists and they will yell
at the ballot Clerks um they will not
yell at you they will yell at the ballot
clerks um and it might uh disadvantage
people to volunteer as election workers
as well um as we should be encouraging
more
participation I also have a story from
Undeclared voters but you heard those
already so I won't repeat thank you
thank you will you be taking questions
happy to are there questions seeing none
thank you next up is Lynn you say I'm
sorry I forgot the last name and I'm
having trouble reading it Briggs Lyn
Briggs from
Amherst can you press that solar button
in front of
you thank you thank you considering
everybody that's gone before me I've
changed a little bit of what I've had to
say but um I support this bill I'm a
registered voter I'm a citizen of New
Hampshire and I support this bill
because it attempts to fix 654 34 as one
of the original six people who have been
in federal court for a year and a half
trying to bring this forward for
everybody to understand um I appreciate
the five or six people that have come
forward taking our hard work thousands
of dollars and thousands of hours to
move forward so I'm glad somebody is
paying attention to our hard work um
there is not an attorney in this state
that would take any of our cases so we
did everything as prosay so nothing that
we do is intended to be negative or or
um stop people from being allowed to
vote that said um we don't want
independence to be left out what we want
is the law to be followed which it says
the first Wednesday in June you are to
declare your party independent is not an
official or an Undeclared is not an
official party Republican and Democrat
is they're also private and it does say
very
clearly sorry it does say very clearly
the um New Hampshire Secretary of State
which is in the test testimony has
advised that he does not have any
written permission from the New
Hampshire GOP opening the primaries to
Undeclared and that's where it all
started so what we're looking for is
that all voters be equal there not be a
second and third class of voter um
whether you're a minority or majority
does not entitle you to more
constitutional rights than anybody else
so I'll keep it short and sweet I am
definitely for it and I thank you for
paying attention to all the work we have
done for the last year and a half will
you be taking questions from the
committee yes okay are there questions
from the committee I doubt it you never
know you don't want to do that then the
fire went off just to prove a point all
right thank you very much uh next up is
uh Wayne sa and on Deck is Sean f
can you press that button in front of
you thank you how's that thank you um my
name is Wayne seya I'm from nashille New
Hampshire I lived in New Hampshire for
30 years and uh I was the um uh um
principal author of The litigation that
Lyn Briggs uh was referring to um the
litigation is was very simple and that
is is that when somebody goes into to
register to vote if you're Undeclared
you can change your vote right there the
same day to a Republican or Democrat and
then after you vote you go up to another
desk and you say I want to change back
to Undeclared and you can do that as a
republican I can't do that so the
Undeclared have an advantage over me as
uh as a Republican and they also have a
um a an advantage over Democrats so and
they can switch they can rearrange how
the presidential vote is is um is trans
it transpires uh one of the dilemmas
here and I'll read here when we went
into court the the court specifically
stated and I'm going to submit these as
exhibits uh the court credits the
testimony of the three plaintiffs in
this case as credible and
straightforward their claims and
arguments were advanced in good faith
the evidence and applicable law however
do not confer standing under these facts
and circumstances the reason why the the
the federal court claimed we didn't have
standing is because um we were claiming
that we were disenfranchised so all of
the individuals that are against this
bill that claimed they disenfranchised
federal court said disenfranchise
doesn't work didn't work for us it can't
work for them um and um when you keep
going uh um and and I apologize I
learned about this about five hours ago
so I I tried to scribble as much as I
could um in the suit it refers to
RSA 654 34 being in conflict with
65914 and and uh that's the issue that
uh my colleague um Mrs Briggs was had
mentioned uh I will mention one other
thing and that is uh on page uh on page
11 of the ruling and I'll get to that
right now and I I I may have stated that
case already I'm going to have to bring
your remarks to a conclusion because
your time has expired um oh good I don't
have to talk anymore that's that's right
um but if you do have a I don't believe
I've seen this court case so if you have
a copy of it I would like to see it I
can't speak for the rest of the
committee but I would personally like to
see it so I I have a copy of the appeal
to the US court of appeals yeah sure
I'll I'll take it just if you don't mind
putting it up there yeah put it up there
on the on the the desk for me and um
because I I I like to read those things
don't always agree with them I just
saying I like to read those
thanks um next up is Sean
F there's good thank
you my name is Sean FEI I represent
gilmington New Hampshire I'm here to
speak for Karen testerman though um what
she' wrote is good afternoon thank you
for allowing my proxy to read my
testimony in support of House Bill
172 the bill before you
applies uh to the presidential and the
state primaries a primary is a selection
process in which a member of a party
selects a candidate or candidates that
will represent the entire uh the entity
in the general election this bill does
not prevent any voter declared or
Undeclared from participating as a voter
in the general
election in the current form RSA 654 34
creates two class of voter in violation
of part one article 11 of the New
Hampshire state constitution that all
men have an equal right to
vote part one of
RSA uh
65534 applies only to the registered
party member who want to change their
party affiliation in order to change
their party affiliation those currently
registered party members must swear
under oath or affirmation of their in
ention to affiliate with the general
supporters the candidates of the party
with which he offers to register or that
the voter does not wish to be registered
as a member of any party and that the
voter wants to be removed from the
checklist of that party a current
registered member of a party must
complete this action by the first
Wednesday in June prior to the
primary according to part one D of
[Music]
654346430
trii allows those who are under oath or
affirmation to participate in the
primary on that day the person decides
to call themselves a member of the party
without oath or affirmation and allows
the person to vote in the party
selection process called the primary on
the same day this is unequal treatment
in a violation of New Hampshire state
constitution part 10 article 11 equality
uh to voter for this reason Karen
testerman asks you to pass House Bill
172 to enable equal treatment of all
voters in New Hampshire thank you from
Karen
testerman will you be taking questions
I'd be happy to okay are there questions
from the committee saying none thank you
um last up is Kristen Evans and
representative gavi can we get the um
blue sheet
please thank you chair and committee
members um uh thank you for the
opportunity to testify in opposition to
hb1 172 for the record my name is
Kristen Evans and I the director of
policy for Abel New Hampshire AEL is a
disability Justice organization that
fights for the civil and human rights of
children and adults with disabilities I
am here today in strong opposition to HP
172 this bill is another brick in
thewall of voter suppression an
unnecessary barrier that will
disproportionately impact voters with
disabilities in New Hampshire we pride
ourselves on Civic engagement on fost
ing robust participation in our
democracy but this bill does the
opposite it restricts access it silences
voices and it actively discourages
participation HB 172 is a solution in
search of a problem there is no evidence
that the same day party registration has
caused any systemic issues in our
elections what this bill does however is
create new hurdles for voters who
already face enough of them people with
disabilities often cannot predict months
in advance which primary they will need
or want to participate in life
circumstances change and limiting when
and how voters can affiliate only
ensures that fewer people can engage in
the Democratic process for people with
disabilities these barriers are even
greater many disabled voters are ready
navigate a voting system that is often
inaccessible lacks proper accommodations
or is riddled with bureaucratic hurdles
that that make participating in
elections far more difficult than it
should be New Hampshire New Hampshire's
Undeclared voter system gives people
flexibility and that flexibility is
essential for full par participation in
democracy taking that away would harm
voters with disabilities stripping them
of a process that helps ensure their
voices are heard hb1 172 strips away the
flexibility that has divined our state's
particip participatory democracy a
flexibility that many voters especially
those with disabilities rely on and
let's be clear the ability to register
and vote in the primary of one's
choosing is not just about convenience
it's about Equity it's about ensuring
that our democracy is accessible to all
voters HB 172 is a step in the wrong
direction it limits Choice it
discourages participation and it ignores
the reality of Voters lives thank you
would you be taking questions yes are
there questions from the committee
seeing none thank you um we had a late
entry Dale Vincent from conquer
I wasn't planning to say anything but I
was so frustrated by hearing how we
should cut off 40% of the population
because they hadn't already decided who
they were going to vote for I have been
an Undeclared voter for probably as long
as I've been in New Hampshire which is
40 some years and I have prided myself
on studying candidates in both parties
and sometimes there is a candidate for
an office that's really outstand
standing in one party and sometimes in a
different party and I feel that we
should be allowed to make that choice at
the polling place and not have to sign
up blindly six months in advance for one
party or the
other that was fast awesome all right
cool great love it will you be taking
questions all right seeing n thank you
um we don't have anyone else signed up
to speak uh on the blue sheet was one in
favor five opposed that did not speak
friendly reminder if you're going to
fill out a pink card don't fill out the
blue sheet because you can't get counted
twice um online was 20 172 yeah uh 29 in
support 573 against nine neutral um with
that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 172 and I'm going
to open up the public hearing on House
Bill 141 relative to campaign
disclosures for limited liabilities
companies and recognize representative
Lane for the purpose of introduction
click
thank you Mr chair and committee we're
going to switch gears here and talk
about campaign Finance uh instead of um
voting
registration um this bill uh closes a
glaring loophole in our campaign Finance
laws uh one that does not even exists
under federal laws currently there's no
mention of limited liability companies
in New Hampshire campaign Finance laws
and each I'm going to call them llc's um
instead of limited liability companies
is treated as its own individual donor
for the purpose of direct campaign
contributions regardless of who controls
that
LLC so I can give the maximum
contribution that I'm allowed to my
favorite candidate and then assuming
that I'm much richer than I really am
now um I can set up unlimited numbers of
llc's and give as much as I wish through
those llc's to my candidate well in
exess of the statutory cap for natural
persons or for corpor operations the
bill requires that a political
contribution by an LLC be allocated to
its members for purposes of determining
whether a member has exceeded
contribution limits in the New Hampshire
statutes the allocation is tied to their
percentage interest in the LLC and
corporations um are included since they
can also be members of an LLC the bill
makes LLC subject to the same political
campaign contributions that we have for
individuals and
corporations so under this bill if an
LLC donates to a candidate then it must
disclose the names and the percentage
ownership of each member to the
candidate which will then be attributed
to that member's contribution limits
under New Hampshire law the bill
provides transparency to prevent wealthy
individuals and corporations from having
undue influence in elections due to a
loophole in New Hampshire's campaign
Finance laws uh we're not the only state
that that has this problem but we are uh
the subject of much of it because our
campaign Finance laws are deemed as um
weak this bill does not stifle or impair
small businesses or prevent them from
participating in campaigns the llc's
targeted by the Bill are not typical
small businesses so this isn't your mom
and pop or an individual setting up to
protect themselves from liabilities
these are companies that come in and
intentionally set up llc's so they can
contribute to
campaigns they are used by both parties
to avoid contribution limits and prevent
transparency if the members of a
traditional LLC wish to donate to a
candidate and protect their identity as
members
they can make a distribution to that
member and let the member donate to the
candidate yes that might be another
loophole but it works and it's more
transparent contrary to what you may
have been told this bill does not
violate citizens united or its progeny
that case permits New Hampshire to lend
it spend to limit spending by
corporations and business entities and
it also promotes transparency this bill
does not prevent Free Speech it simply
requires individuals and corporations to
abide by the contribution limits that we
set out in our laws so ultimately
closing this loophole is a question of
fairness and
transparency most of us can agree that
the amount of money that is going into
our uh top tier elections is
objectionable and it goes up every year
this bill helps eradicate the effect of
laws or other loopholes that allow
enterprising individuals enterprising
wealthy individuals to evade the intent
of state legislators and determining
Fair contribution limits above which an
individual shall not go whether that
individual is a natural person or a
limited liability company under the law
person can mean a corporation a limited
liabil ability company or a natural
person so I ask for your support to
improve our campaign Finance laws by
improving transparency and reducing the
dark money that flows into New Hampshire
campaigns thank you and yes I'll take
questions okay and you had 10 seconds
left so that's like a great job you on
the five minute clock that makes up for
last time yeah yeah you but you I think
what's impressive here is like
percentage wise on the five minute clock
you were you n like you did the best out
of everybody on the five minute clock um
questions from the committee all right
seeing none thank you um I only have one
other card for this so oliv is Inc um so
representative gusovsky if you could
grab that uh grab that blue sheet for me
I'm going to trust but verify I only
have one other
yeah good afternoon uh members of the
committee my favorite topic this LLC
loophole um why we're in open democracy
is in support of house bill one
41 um we need to reduce the influence of
big money in our politics and increase
the voices of everyday citizens this
bill provides transparency and
accountability um as you know there's
limits that anyone can give um and those
limits are
$15,000 for any individual so if I if I
wanted to give Connie Lane
$15,000 I could uh but if I have a
second company I can give her
$30,000 um but we also have another
loophole in our law called the the
political advocacy committee that can
give unlimited donations so these
limited liability companies should just
be creating political or you know
political organizations and just funnel
money through our our laws but uh or the
Swiss cheese of our laws I want to um
first talk about
2010 um 2010 um gorial candidate John
Stevens caused a stir by raising over
$100,000 from 30 limited liability
corporations
in Massachusetts and Connecticut so out
of state money um that were Dunkin
Donuts
franchised um August 18th uh this is my
daughter's birthday 13 llc's gave
governatori candidate Kevin Smith um the
maximum amount um half of Smith's
$324,000 of contributions came from
llc's at the same address in
Massachusetts
um we've seen multiple Li liability
companies use candidates on uh from from
both from both sides of the aisle have
used the LLC Loop loophole to funnel
money into their campaign I'm going to
go to
2020 uh 12 where Kevin landan uh wrote a
story about campaign contributions and
these ones are fun decking the decking
company get gave the max amount but then
decking 18
3209 l C and decking Atlantic
1720 gave another amount of money and
they all came from the same address so
we know they're connected in some way
shape or
form that to bring your remarks to a
conclusion okay uh well I I I go through
multiple different campaign Cycles but
so I'll just skip to the last 2024 uh we
saw key Auto Group make a lot of LLC
contributions over the limit um to a
candidate that took 20 1 million in
political advocacy committee money
dollars um this bill has been tried
multiple times um without success but
it's important that you fix this
loophole before the next election but I
have said that multiple times
before happy to take any
questions questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um oh
you've already packaged up the blue
sheet way ahead of me um on the blue
sheet there were three support zero
against on online there was 196 in
support six opposed and one neutral with
that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 141 and I'm going
to open the public hearing on House Bill
175 represent recognize uh
representative Mirad um for purpose of
introduction who has requested 45 to 75
minutes or the equivalent of one lecture
class
so but we've already seen the uh
popularity of your of your classes today
haven't we Oh I thought it was funny all
right my name is russ
mad I represent Grafton District 12 Etna
towns of Etna lime Hanover New Hampshire
um I live in Hanover where I work as a
teacher and uh and my and my number one
worry when I started my career Mr chair
was that I would run out of things to
say before the class
ended and uh I've been working on that
ever
since so so um this bill House Bill
175 would um prohibit independent groups
that spend money on campaigns and and
candidates from coordinating their
expenditures it's an anti-coordination
bill um there are different limits for
how much independent groups can spend
and how much candidates can spend in
some cases there's no limits for for
some independent groups so if candidates
can coordinate with independent groups
they can get around the limits they're
in the
law and and they can spend an unlimited
amount and also in some cases they won't
have to reveal they they get around
contribution limits and they also get
around disclosure limits so they don't
have to show who's giving them money how
much money they're getting or what
they're spending it
on as the law would ordinarily require
candidates to do so it's a it's it's a
huge back door around all of the rules
in New Hampshire campaign Finance law
that um that we apply to candidates now
that
massive back door that massive ability
to just escape the burden of campaign
Finance disclosure and contribution
rules is something that I think the
party Elites want I think party Elites
and both parties want this party Elites
and both parties there's no innocence
you know in politics
party Elites and both parties love money
they want money in unlimited amounts and
they're really really crafty about
figuring out how to get it this is not a
bill that the party Elites are going to
jump up and down about they're going to
say oh look at that naive teacher from
Handover who thinks you know we can
limit we can we can actually do
something about the problem of big money
in politics the only people who might
want this bill are citizens who are
worried about big money in politics and
it's one of the interesting things if
you look at polling you know it's just
amazing to see how much Democrats and
Republicans disagree you get 80% of
Republicans on this versus 10 you know 8
n 90% opposing the Democrats one of the
only thing you get big numbers on the
same side is about the the role of big
money in politics you know get like 80%
of Republicans saying that's a problem
get 85 90% of Democrats saying that's a
problem this spills an attempt to make a
difference about with respect to to that
problem by making sure that independent
expenditures and that's a term that
shows up in New Hampshire rsas we' put
that in the law independent
expenditures make sure that independent
expenditures are actually
independent and by the way you know look
let's look at some campaign Finance laws
that you know that that let's say I
think I don't know maybe they're not
very partisan look at citizens united
citizens united uses the term
independent expenditures citizens united
says that independent expenditures are
those that are made without
pre-arrangement or coordination with
candidates and it and it says that those
expenditures shouldn't have to have
limits but that but that expenditures
that candidates make you know that's
totally reasonable for the law to limit
what the you know to to regulate what
candidates make and so even the the just
the terms of citizens united depend on
this idea of making independent
expenditures independent if we have a
massive lowle that makes these
independent expenditures not indep
dependent none of this makes any sense
and and and it's a huge deception on the
public so so this bill is is an effort
to you know to address that problem and
and and and solve that problem and uh Mr
chair um I I I I would um take questions
if there are
any are questions from the
committee oh representative
link uh thank you for taking my question
um isn't
it's my understanding that this was a
new ruling the letter from the Attorney
General's office interpreting our
statutes that for years we had what you
talked about that there was an
anti-coordination and this term we had a
new
interpretation um so are you attempting
to address that that came up in this
election I do think that it's an
increasing problem in New Hampshire
campaigns and that the door right now is
open to
coordination um and but you know look
there are 20 states that have that have
done the same thing this is something
that if you if you if you have the term
independent expenditure in your laws as
New Hampshire does then you have a
reason to make sure they're independent
and it's not just a response to one
letter by one attorney
general further questions from the
committee saying none thank you um next
up is uh Kaye a AO on behalf of Aaron
mcken on Deck is Olivia zinc I don't
have any other cards for
175 um so representative can you grab
that blue sheet for me um thank you
chairman Barry and members of the
committee for the record my name is kayy
of stadio I a Durham voter and public
policy fellow with open democracy and
today I am reading testimony in support
of HB 175 on behalf of Aaron mcken who
is senior legal counsel at um The
Campaign Legal Center and since this is
seven pages I will spare you from the
legal jargon and just read a little
summary of it and hope that you will all
peruse this on your own time so uh Aaron
says that campaign Legal Center
carefully reviewed HB 175 and found that
it is well crafted in in a
constitutional piece of legislation as
explained further in the seven pages HB
175 would close critical gaps in New
Hampshire's law that allow political
advoc advocacy organizations to raise
unlimited contributions and funnel those
directly to candidates closing these
gaps prevents circumvention of
contribution limits to candidates
ensuring such limits curb quote the
actuality and appearance of corruption
resulting from large individual Finance
contributions importantly HB 175 also
strengthens New Hampshire's coordination
law to comprehensively account for the
ways in which candidates and outside
groups coordinate their spending the
bill would clarify and expand the types
of conduct that constitute coordination
and the kinds of election spending
subject to coordination rules thereby
preventing outside groups from
circumventing contribution limits as the
US Supreme Court has recognized
regulating coordinated expenditures
advances the same anti-corruption
interests as limits on contributions and
quote prevents attempts to circumvent
the limits through pre-arranged or
coordinated expenditures accounting to
disguise contribution
I urge you to support this bill will we
be taking questions from the committee
sure if I can answer any are there
questions from the committee seeing none
thank you next up and last up is Olivia
zinc and the Blue Shield we have
you okay I think this is a lot of times
you've heard from me today so Olivia
zinc a voter in Franklin executive
director of open democracy and I'm here
to testify in favor of House Bill
175 our democracy to be effective for
our democracy to be effective candidates
and elected officials need to answer to
their constituents not wealthy special
interests campaign contribution limits
play an important role in protecting
this to reduce the undue influence of
wealthy donors and politics there must
be guard rails against political
corruption um and and um you know we
talk about coordination candidates can
put things on their website and special
interest in pack groups can take them so
what we call that red boxing in the
campaign Finance world so on page two um
you know the the ab c d talks about that
red boxing so if you put something in a
red in a on your own website and says
for four voters to know and then the
political committees take the four
voters to know information and put it in
an ad right so that is what uh this is
trying to do is that sort of red boxing
um that happens um with coordinated
spending this also is uh
valuable for candidates uh to evade
campaign limits direct contributions and
coordinate with outside Spenders
remember outside Spenders in New
Hampshire are mostly out of state
Spenders they're they're big money
coming in from out of state it's not
local money that's being spent to
influence our Liv ction s um house bill
um 472 creates and expands upon a
definition def the definition of
coordinated and independent expenditure
clearly outlining the difference between
these two and eliminating
loopholes um right now our law is Swiss
cheese undetected coordination of Roads
uh accountability for everyday voters um
and and we need to make sure that
Millionaires and billionaires aren't
able to funnel unlimited money and drown
out the voices of local New Hampshire
voters for this reason I urge you to
vote a to pass on
175 and support Integrity in political
campaigns and I'm happy to take any
questions other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you with
that I'm going to close the public
hearing on House Bill
175 uh the blue sheet was one person
signed in in support report
online
was uh 137 in support 8 oppose Zer
neutral that we're going to close that
uh hearing with the public hearing we're
going to open up the noticed executive
session I'm going to uh begin open the
executive session for cacr 5 relating to
absentee vs providing that no excuse
shall be needed by the voter to receive
an absentee ballot and I will recognize
representative prudom O'Brien for a
motion I move itl is there a
second representative qua
seconds it's okay we're on discussion on
the motion of inexpedient to legislate
on cacr five is there discussion on the
motion representative Lanes
recognized um I would like to have a
discussion about this because we haven't
really had one and I would like to know
why when there's no evidence of any
fraud in
absentee ballot states there's 37 States
states that do this what would convince
folks or what is the issue that is
holding people back from doing this
particularly in New Hampshire where
there's virtually no fraud they can't
nobody's proved
it further questions from the
committee no one wants to answer huh I
guess no one wants to answer um was
anyone else wish to speak are you ready
for the vote the clerk will call the
representative qua yes representative
pom O'Brien yes representative Burnham
yes representative weary yes
representative wood yes representative
Harry bullia yes representative
C yes representative gzowski yes
representative toner yes representative
Lane no representative Ward no
representative Gilmore no representative
Mirad no representative Bay
no Representative wilam no
representative Nome
nope representative Howard
no chairman Barry chair votes yes with
that the motion of inexpedient legislate
carries on a vote of 10 to8 um
representative F O'Brien you'll be
responsible for the majority report uh
representative Lane who will be
responsible for a Minority Report me
representative Lane will be responsible
for minority Port that I will close the
executive session after I type in my
notes
here sorry represent O'Brien has a
longer name and might don't type that
fast there we
go it's on the public documents I want
to make it nice represent Lane all right
there we go okay with that I will close
the executive session for uh cacr 5 and
I will open the executive session for
House Bill
136 uh extending the time period for
delivery of V ballots from 5:00 P p.m.
to the close of polls and I will
recognize representative wood for a
motion can you turn your mic on
representative thank you sorry about
that i' like to make a motion on HB 136
move it to itl representative wood moves
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
136 is there a second I second the
motion representative second
representative qua seconds the motion is
there discussion on the motion of any
speed to legislate on house B
136 seeing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the
rooll representative qua yes
representative P O'Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative C yes representative
gazowsky yes representative toner yes
representative Lane
no representative Ward no representative
Gilmore no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no Representative
wilham no representative Nome no
representative Howard no chairman Barry
chair votes yes without the motion of
inexpedient to legislated on house bull
uh 136 carries on a vote of 10 to8 uh
representative prudo O'Brien you'll be
responsible for the majority report who
will be a represent land who will get me
a Minority
Report I'm not sure yet but I'll get
your name soon all right I'm G to put
you down in the interum does that work
obviously that can
change uh yeah they need I need them I'm
going to try to get to although they
didn't put the ones I sent last time on
the calendar but
um oh I'm sorry I had representative
wood for the majority report my
apologies I have it it's already written
it um okay with that I will close the
executive session on House Bill 136 and
uh representative Lane is currently down
from Minority Report but she will change
she that might change um I think we're
going to go
to I'm try to get the one that I know
we're going to be together on
here um nope that's not
it trying to get one more out before
four we done 498 no um with I'm going to
open up the notice executive session for
house bow 498 relative to to when a
person may receive an absentee ballot
I'm going recognize representative Lane
for a motion um I move that we itl uh HB
498 representative Lane moves
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
498 is there a second second
representative Ward seconds is there any
discussion on the motion of any speeding
to legislate on house po
498 hearing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the role
doing great yep they all love you yeah
oh thank you all right here we go
representative qua yes representative
pum O'Brien yes representative Burnham
yes representative weary yes
representative wood yes representative
Harvey Bia yes representative C yes
representative gzowski yes
representative toner yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Gilmore yes
representative head yes representative
Bay yes representative wilham yes
representative Nome yes representative
Howard yes chairman Barry the chair
votes yes and with that the motion of
inexpedient to legislate carries on a
vote of 18 to Zer is there any objection
to this bill being placed on the consent
calendar hearing none the bill will be
placed on consent calendar
representative Lane do you know who will
be responsible for the
report I want to put you down in the
inim with that I'm going to recess the
notice executive session
uh and we're going to go back to
hearings cuz it's 2:41 so I'm going to
open the public hearing for House Bill
311 FN relative to permissible campaign
contributions by business organizations
and labor unions and I will recognize
representative Reed for the purpose of
introduction representative Reed welcome
to election law thank you so much um my
first one of the year in election law uh
thank you Mr chair and thank you
honorable members for the record my name
is Ellen Reed I represent Rockingham 10
which is New Market and new
Fields uh HB 311 is a long overdue
housekeeping
bill so little bit of history in 1907
President Roosevelt signed into law the
Tillman act which stands to this day it
is a federal prohibition on corporate
political
donations excuse me one second while I
bring up a
quote it's uh ought for federal
candidates the quote from Teddy
Roosevelt to Congress is all
contributions by corporations to any
political committee or for any political
purpose should be forbidden by law
directors should not be permitted to use
stockholders money and remember that
stockholders money because we'll later
call that treasury or general funds for
such purposes and moreover a Prohibition
of this kind would be as far as it went
an effective method of stopping the
evils aimed at in Corrupt Practices
acts wildly
popular right after the Tillman Act was
signed many many States including New
Hampshire signed their own state level
prohibitions on corporate donations
political
donations then after that as we get
later into the 20th century and unions
become more of a thing uh we also put a
type of ban on Union donations but when
we did the Union donations it did not
look like the existing corporate
donation ban the union donation ban was
very specific because it made two
different source of funds distinct the
treasury which is the general funds in
this case from member dues union dues
was prohibited you cannot make political
contributions a union cannot from their
dues from their General funds from their
treasury but what it said is that you
can in fact create a segregated fund
that is funded through voluntary
donations to then be given for political
contributions and that was legal so we
created this kind of distinct system for
unions okay so we have a complete ban on
corporations and a kind of half ban on
unions and then in 1999 Kennedy V
Gardner New Hampshire Supreme Court case
the Supreme Court struck down
the corporate ban as being overly
broad they didn't say that it would um
be
unconstitutional if it had been worded
like the union ban and I'm looking for
the quote from that right now um but
it's it said there is of course a simple
solution to this simple problem the
general court can easily and effectively
amend the statute to reflect its actual
constitutional intent meaning that if we
simply re write the corporate ban
instead of a complete General ban
rewrite it like the union ban then it
would be constitutional they gave us
that directive in
1999 what we then did is we struck out
the corporate ban in its entirety did
not replace it so now for the last 26
years we've had a partial ban on Union
donations from Union treasury funds but
a uh complete free-for-all on corporate
donations we have no ban whatsoever on
corporate donations in the state so HB
311 does exactly what the Supreme Court
said in the Kennedy V Garder case in
1999 um a previous version of this bill
I simply took the language on the unions
and duplicated it substituting in a
different paragraph businesses and then
a member who is no longer uh in the
house and was on Election L at the time
wrote a Minority Report stating that I
was somehow trying to treat unions and
corporations differently when in fact
this is exactly the opposite so what I
have done here is instead of duplicating
a paragraph I shoved businesses into the
paragraph that unions are currently in
so that you can see very clearly that
the same exact language and the same
exact paragraph applies equally to
businesses and unions which is a ban on
General treasury funds being used for
corporate donations so that stockholder
shareholder stakeholder funds you can't
spend those funds because those were not
given to you for political purposes but
you can create a segregated fund what we
today call a pack to spend uh political
expenditures out
of and I'll just close by saying that um
Banning the corporate fiddling in our
elections is one of the most broadly
popular maybe not amongst politicians
but amongst the people regardless of
political stripe everyone hates the idea
that our elections are bought and paid
for everybody just talk to regular Rank
and file whoever and I'll close with
that happy to answer
questions okay questions from the
committee seeing none thank you I only
have one pink card so representative
gusowski gzowski if you can please get
the uh blue sheet for me um and the only
card I have is for Olivia
zinc um and just so members will be on
notice we will go back into executive
session after um Missy times expires um
for the record my name is Olivia zinc
executive director at open democracy and
I'm here in support of House Bill 311 um
I want to just say that this prohibits
business organizations from making
political contribution in the wake of
Garder or Kennedy versus Garder which
was a 1999 decision so it's 25 years old
um I know the prime sponsor just said it
was a Supreme Court but I have that it's
a US District Court um that struck um
down a ban on the business organization
this ban was repealed from New Hampshire
law in 2011 so even though the court
Struck it down in 1999 the election law
uh repealed it uh in
2011 um despite this
case um it it really
said it this the judge gave us the facts
in this case and they said uh in the
word words exploited by the legislature
are clear and um
unambiguous and the evidence to the
intent to Pro preclude corporations from
making political contribution unless
those sources so they just want you to
make segregated funds and make sure that
the sources are disclosed it's very
simple the court told you how to fix it
and to to to make it the Constitutional
intent um you know it does exactly what
union we have for unions so um it just
brings Equity into the different
entities so that corporations don't get
more influence in our elections and um
make them contribute through segregated
funds or volunteer contributions
currently there's a law that utility
companies can't give money to political
candidates and have them used for their
rate payers but because they're not
going through a segregated fund we don't
know if the if those utility donations
are um are are fungible or if they're uh
you know I I think many people do not
want eversource's political
contributions to be part of the rates
that they pay to the electricity company
um or any other public utility um so
please uh this does have a straight line
um from The Gardener decision um to make
sure that we have a level play playing
field for corporate spending um so ple I
urge you to do the right thing and
support this bill and with that I'm
happy to take questions other questions
from the committee representative Lane
um could you speak to whether or not
this would violate citizens united no
this would not violate citizens united
because corporations can still make
political contributions they just have
to do it through through a segregated
fund thank you further questions from
the committee seeing none thank you um
on the blue sheet there was one signed
in uh in support no opposed online there
was excuse
me there was 174 in support nine opposed
and zero neutral with that I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
311 we're going to go back into the
noticed executive session uh we're going
to open up the executive session for
House Bill 2
288 uh that's House Bill 288 requires
that absentee ballots be requested at
least 6 months prior to any election um
for which the absentee ballot is
requested and I will recognize
representative Wei for a motion I'd like
to make a motion of ought to pass
representative Wei makes a motion of
ought to pass is there a second
representative wood seconds are there
any amendments to the bill yes sir
representative we would you like to move
an amendment yes uh the uh committee has
before them uh had been passed out
amendment
[Music]
2025-the that number again I'm sorry yes
it's uh 2025
d03
49h representative wey moves Amendment
d349 H to House Bill 288 is there a
second second representative wood second
we're now on discussion of the amendment
representative Wy would you like to
speak to your motion yes thank you um it
uh the amendment clarifies the uaba
voters um
for um that process uh they have to fill
out the federal official postcard no
earlier than January of a calendar year
in which an election occurs federal
election occurs all other application um
so so that's how that is aspect is
addressed and then uh here the um
remaining applicant forms would be uh
received or postmarked within six months
of the election so um that uh basically
it uh it contains the intent of the
original thing but corrects it for the
uh uaba and the title and the analysis
have also been amended to uh more
accurately reflect the nature of the uh
Bill further discussion on the
amendment hearing none are you ready for
the question the vote is on adoption of
the amendment we may adopt via voice
vote all in favor of adopting Amendment
2025 j 0349 h say I all opposed say nay
the eyes have it representative weary is
recognize for a motion I'd like to make
a motion of ought to pass with the
amendment representative Wei um makes
the motion of ought to pass as Amendment
on House Bill 288 with Amendment 2025
349 is there a second
second representative wood second is
there discussion on the bill as
amended representative Lane is
recognized uh I I appreciate um the
intent of this bill but um I will be
voting against it because it creates two
different classes of Voters one then are
not yukaba and and ones that are and um
so I I hope we can solve this problem
another way but that's my thoughts Is
there further discussion on the motion
of V to pass as amended on House Bill
288 seeing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the
rooll representative qua yes
representative pum O'Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Boya yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes representative toner yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative
Gilmore no representative Mirad no
representative Bay no Representative
wilham no representative Nome no
representative Howard no chairman Barry
chair votes yes with that the motion of
ought to pass as Amendment passes
carries on a vote of 10 to8
representative we you'll be responsible
for the majority report representative
Lane do you know who will be responser
for the Minority
Report as as per as our practice now I
will put you down um with that I am
going to close the executive session for
House Bill
288 time is it five more minutes um
going to open up the executive session
for House Bill uh 29 have we done 294
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session for House Bill 294 and I will
recognize representative Lane to make a
motion 294 oh okay um I will make a
motion of ought to pass on 294 there's a
motion of ought to pass by two on House
Bill 294 is there a
second representative Ward seconds is
there discussion on the motion of ought
to pass on House Bill 294
hearing none are you ready for the
question the clerk will call the
role my God sorry about that
representative qua yes representative
pum Brien yes representative Burnham yes
representative we yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes representative toner yes
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative
wilham yes representative Nome yes
representative Howard yes chairman Barry
chair votes yes with that the motion of
V to pass carries on a vote on on motion
V to pass on House Bill 294 cares on a
vote of 18 to zero um without objection
this bill will be placed on consent
counter hearing not it has a fiscal note
uh it doesn't
on it doesn't I'm going to trust verify
because I was I don't think there no cuz
no this is removing of a statute so no
there's no fiscal note um so without
objection this bill will be placed on
consent calendar that I'm going to close
the uh representative Lane I guess I'll
put you down for the
report you're going to be very busy um
with that I'm going to close the
executive session on House Bill
294 and I will open up the executive
session for House Bill 344 uh enabling
enables the processing of absentee
ballots before the election day uh I
will make a motion of inexpedient to
legislate is there a
second representative qua seconds me
we're on a discussion of the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
344 would any member like to be
recognized hearing none are you ready
for the
vote the clerk will call the role on the
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
house Bill
344 representative qua yes
representative Poma ran yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Balia yes
representative C yes representative
goovi yes representative toner yes
representative Lane no representative
ative Ward no representative Gilmore no
representative Mirad no representative
Bay no Representative wilham no
representative Nome no representative
Howard no chairman Barry chair votes yes
with that the motion of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 344 carries on a
vote of 10 to zero uh I will be
responsible for the majority report
representative Lane do we know who will
be doing my
minority 10
to8 I'm sorry did I did I stutter
through it sorry oh 10 to8 excuse me 10
to8 10 to8 and she wrote it down
apparently that's not how that
works woo all right uh representative
Lane do you know who will be responsible
for the Minority
Report yeah um we only have 1 minute
left so I'm oh I'm going to close the
executive session on 344 and we've got 1
minute uh before we do the next hearing
so a couple of housekeeping things um I
will send out the link but I showed the
ranking member and the vice chairman
um a form that I have made using the
license we get from Microsoft Office um
with via the state um so I'll send it
out in a BCC U but that is how I want
you to send in committee reports going
forward because we have so many um it's
going to have it has a drop- down menu
on it you can select who you are it has
a drop- down menu for uh the bill number
and the name um and then it has the
motion you're making um and it basically
requests all the information that you
would give to me in email but instead of
having a thousand different emails
bouncing around I'll have it in one nice
spot when you click submit on that it
goes to three people so be conscient
that when you click submit it's going to
three people it's going to myself the
ranking member and the vice chairman um
if you have if you submit something and
you need be changes obviously feel free
to reach out to me and we will make
those make that Arrangement but this
will help me to put everything kind of
in one bucket um so I'm not digging
through umen emails trying to because
some people are emailing me on my
campaign email address the people are
it's all over the place um so I would
work with your respective party leader
in how that will work inside your
process um like I know for my friends on
the Democrats you guys usually send it
to representative Lane and she does
whatever she does with it and then she
sends it to me um however you guys work
that into your process that's fine um I
don't care but I want to receive it
through that link um and I'll make the
the email title very obvious but that
will help um and if anybody sees
anything that should be added to that
form I'm happy to add it um but once
again when you click submit it's it's
immediately it goes to me the ranking
member and the vice chairman um so
there's there won't be any um oh I sent
it in or whatever it's it will be
there's no there will be three people
are immediately receive it so um any
have any questions on that okay um and
with that we will uh recess the notice
executive
session and uh we will open up we just
did that one uh we will open up the
public hearing for House Bill 364
relative to ballots delivered to Elder
Care
Facilities um I don't even know whose
bill this is oh represent Lanes Bill oh
yeah this is the bill that I was
supposed to do last week and I just
missed it um my apologies yeah we were
supposed to do this bill last week and I
just I just missed it so now we're doing
it represent you're like a frequent
flyer today I
am um I'm Connie Lane I represent uh
marac District uh 16 which is uh
conquered W
two um I'm going to do something rather
unusual this bill uh was intended to uh
repeal a bill that we passed last year
uh I had been asked uh to put in this
bill uh and now the people that asked me
no longer seem to think they need it so
I am going to respectfully ask that all
of you itl my
bill cannot wait to itl your bill I'll
take questions if you want um are there
questions for the
committee um all right seeing none um
please rejoin yes representative
Mirad well the good news is
um I'm not writing a report for that
one the good news is actually we can we
could if you want wanted to indulge you
because we do have the notice executive
language so if you want to itl it we can
we can do it U yeah we can do it right
now if well my my agreement is if the
ranking member agrees to it so if the
ranking member agrees to itl her own
bill you know otherwise we can do it
next week and notice it next week um so
with that I guess uh I guess I'll look
online and read up the hearings um see
how many people signed in for the now
yeah well let me let me finish the
hearing first because I got to do the I
got to do the things um
um
364 I are you sure you want to right
this a lot of people like oh oh no a lot
of people hate this spell actually um so
uh online there were 67 in support 349
opposed and zero neutral um
representative toner can you grab that
uh did we lose representative
gasowski did
he um representative l um do you have
any objection to executing this bill
today uh no
okay all right A lot of people like this
bill are you sure about a lot of people
signed in here uh five five in support
zero opposed um I don't have any pink
cards I already read online so with that
I will close the public hearing on House
Bill 364 we don't have any more public
hearings today so we're just going to
finish off executive session and maybe
even go home a little early who knows um
all right going to open up the executive
session uh of the new of the house
election law committee U going to do an
unnoticed executive session on House
Bill 364 relative to ballots delivered
to Elder Care Facilities uh and you know
what represent you said you didn't want
to kill your own bill okay I mean I used
to love doing that I used to love
killing my own bills so U representative
Lane is recognized for a motion uh I
moved to I uh House Bill 364
representative Wilhelm quickly jumps in
to kill your bill
um I have to find it's okay we've got
time how dare you how dare you
364 yes
ma'am at that we've got it all right
that motion uh a motion of inexpedient
to legislate by represent Lane seconded
a vigorous second by representative
Wilhelm um seemed very joyful to do it
it was very strange
um are you ready for the
question here the clerk will call the
role on the motion of inexpedient to
legislator House Bill
364 okay representative qua yes
representative Poma Bryan Yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes representative toner yes
representative Lane
yes representative
Ward
yes uh representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay
yes representative willham yes
representative Nome yes representative
Howard
yes hang
on and chairman Barry chair votes yes
without the motion of inexpedient to
legislator on House Bill 364 carries on
a vote of 18 to Zer is there any
objection to this bill being placed on
the consent calendar hearing none the
bill will be placed on consent calendar
representative Lane you have a lot of
reports would you like me to take care
of this two- sentence report which will
include the sponsor asked for to be
withdrawn okay um see I'll get that take
care in that I'll use my new link and
everything it'll be great um with that
we're going to close the executive
session on House Bill
364 and we're going to open up the
executive session for um House Bill 345
which is being recessed so 345 is
recessed uh we are going to open up the
executive session for House Bill
um relative to whether conditions which
enable absentee voting and
representative toner is recognized for a
motion i' like to make a motion of itl
Representative toner makes the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
403 is there a second a second that
representative pral Bri seconds is there
discussion on the motion of inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill
403 seeing none are you ready for the
question clerk will call the role on the
motion of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill 403
representative qua yes representative P
Brian yes representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Balia yes
representative C yes representative
gzowski yes representative toner yes
representative Lane no representative
Ward no representative Gilmore no
representative Mirad no representative
Bay no Representative wilham no
representative Nome no representative
Howard
no chairman Barry chair votes yes with
that the motion of in speaking to
legislate carries on a vote of 10
to8 um representative toner you'll be
responsible for the majority report
representative Lane do we know who will
be doing The Minority Report all right
representative Lanes be a frequent flyer
on The Minority Report all right with
that I'm going to close the executive
session on House Bill 403 uh 418 will be
recessed and we'll be referred to the
subcommittee which we're going to talk
about in a second um how we're going to
open up the oh 423 is the perennial
recess um so 423 is recessed we only
have one more um which is house
bill
for I'm missing a bill in here I missed
one uh Mr chairman is it 464 no we're
about to do 464 but I'm missing oh no no
it is 464 I'm sorry no it is it is it is
I'm sorry it is I I got confused by my
paperwork uh going to open up the
um the executive session for House Bill
464 prohibiting candidates from
political offices from participating in
counting ballots and representative
gusovsky gzowski is recognized I like to
make a motion of OTP please
Representative gusowski makes a mission
makes a motion of ought to pass is there
a second I second represent
representative Burnham seconds um are
there any
amendments I'll uh yes oh we actually
how you can move the you're I mean your
name's on it so that well that's we were
going to move anyways brother so go for
oh actually you can't do it because you
are not a member of this committee um
sorry yeah I know but our rules our
rules do not allow for uh Subs to make
uh they can't make motions they can't do
amendments only thing you can do is vote
so I'm sorry about that that's not I
think it would be great because your
name is loading on the amendment so
we'll go back to representative gasi um
who moves Amendment yes okay
representative gusowski is going to move
Amendment 202-9665
there you go all right so we are now on
discussion of the amendment
202-9665
uh would anyone like to speak to the
amendment representative Howard would
you like to speak to the amendment that
your name is on yes I would thank you Mr
chair uh HB 464 in this amendment uh is
intended to remove any potential image
of a conflict of interest and is about
public
transparency uh so we can prevent any
illusion of interference
uh this amendment uh it specifies
exactly what elected positions would be
allowed to handle these ballots uh
because obviously there are some that
are statutorily and constitutionally
allowed uh and supposed to do these jobs
so uh this amendment fixes uh some of
the errors in the original and I hope to
gain your support thank you okay great
day to sub further discussion on the
amendment hearing none are you ready for
the question all those in favor of
adopting amendment 20251 n6h to House
Bill 464 say I I all opposed say nay the
eyes hav it with that um house bill with
that the amendment is adopted
representative ton representative
gzowski is recognized for a motion yes I
like to make a motion to ought to pass
as amended Representative gzowski makes
the motion of ought to pass as amended
to House Bill 464 with Amendment
2025-the is there a second second rep
multiple seconds but we'll credit
representative Burnham um we're now on
discussion on the bill as amended is
there discussion on the bill as
amended hearing none are you ready for
the question the clerk will call the
role on the motion of ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 464 with Amendment
d016 representative qua yes
representative pom O'Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
representative weary yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Balia yes
representative
C yes representative kovski yes
representative toner yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Bay yes representative willham yes
representative Nome yes representative
Howard yes chairman Barry
chair votes yes and with that the motion
of ought to pass on ought to pass is
amended on House Bill 464 carries on a
vote of 18 to Z is there any objection
to this bill being placed on the consent
calendar hearing none the bill will be
placed on the consent calendar um
there's no more votes today
um uh I thought I did but I'll say it
again I'm recessing House Bill
686 that make there you go if I didn't
say that I apologize um I had it
scratched off already okay um one more
quick housekeeping item so I'm going to
send email out about uh the link with
the reports um we have formed a
subcommittee let me read the
subcommittee title real fast should have
had that
ready Outlook I might apologize uh but
anyways we formed a subcommittee
representative we is the chair um it's
going to look at um basically most a lot
of the bills we've looked at in the last
two weeks basically involving um uh
voter registration definition of dool
residency um I'll read to you the formal
charge here but they're basically what
they're going to look at is under the
context of some of the bills that we've
uh recessed um which which
ones basically they're going to explore
the court cases that have been out there
that would be relevant to this um and
draft a report um and I imagine there
will be a majority and a Minority Report
coming out of that committee um but
they're going to meet representative we
wins the first
meeting this Friday what time 930 9:30
okay let me find the no let me find the
notice for and I can read it so I can do
this
officially it's already been formed they
just didn't have bills yet
um where'd You
Go
Robin my sent for sorry guys I'm trying
to get us out of here that
help uh yeah well I I need I want to
read the notice um
form all right here we go okay so uh
forming the subcommittee the election
law subcommittee on voter registration
and impacts of non-resident voting uh
the first name chairman the first name
members have the authority to schedule
meetings shall act as chair as I said
that that is representative weie um
they've already noticed uh a bunch of
bills for this Friday the committee
maintains maintains possession of the
bill so we actually exec a couple of
them today those reports aren't going to
be held they're going to be transmitted
to the clerk as you guys have probably
gathered trying to get things out of the
committee and not hold on to them um but
uh you know please show up if you want
to show up uh you know you can obviously
sit in the crowd um with that uh I don't
think we have more business I will see
you guys for next Tuesday um and
Thursday for voting and I will send that
link around right now okay all right
I'll see you guys on
Tuesday
e e